Hey,
what's going on is bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And Ah,
just check it it on you.
You cubicle dwelling cunts.
Um,
you know something,
I'd feel bad for you if you're sitting in a cubicle right now,
but I'm just so full of myself that I just don't have time to have empathy.
I'm just going to sit here and a big hot tub with my own white privilege.
And speaking of other white males.
Yes.
Why would you have another white male on your podcast?
You know why?
Because I'm not woke.
Um,
200% wrong today,
Bill.
200% wrong.
It's right.
Just when you thought the percentage couldn't go any higher.
I have the wonderful,
they always classy.
One of the few gentlemen.
My wife loves you like she get like that one night we all hung up.
Sorry.
Let me just nay Craig and natives here.
Not because he loves me,
not because he actually tried to pass the puck to me in the slot and I still
shot her right into the goalies fucking glove.
Remember that fucking went around the defense man,
he's here because he has a new album comedy album that's available on iTunes and
Amazon and all over the Internet called preferred customers.
Uh,
one of my favorite people,
one of my favorite comics,
Nate Craig,
welcome bill.
Thanks for it.
First of all,
I want to say I love,
we all love Nia as well and man,
the gentleman introduction.
I,
I'll take it run and buddy.
Thank you.
We talking about,
yeah,
the amount of times that you've sent flowers.
You've sent cards because you know,
we had a kid and all of that shit.
You're,
you're,
you're a class act.
You're a Midwest guy.
What does it feel to be living out here in Hollywood and just referred to as a,
did they treat you like a fly over comic?
Ah,
yet some of the responses
their responses
get from,
uh,
from being from the Midwest.
There are pretty hilarious.
People just don't,
they think you're a Trump supporter who just say Wisconsin and people laugh in
your face.
Now.
You think that's because the badgers last three fucking rose bowls on a row.
Well that's got something to do with it.
Yeah.
How could it not?
You gotta you gotta they gotta do something,
man.
Whiskey like bat way.
We,
if you had to bet money who's taken the next title?
And it's hard with a college cause everybody fucking leaves.
But basketball you got a better chance in basketball or football.
Wisconsin,
Wisconsin.
Man.
We're not leaving that state.
You fucking cheesy.
Eaton motherfucker football for sure.
Football.
Yeah.
I don't know if I'm,
I thought your basketball team was all right.
They were until they lost their hall of fame had coach because uh,
because what happened?
What happened?
Oh,
side fees is sidepiece went public.
Oh yeah.
Why does that get you fired?
Uh,
you know,
I don't know.
I think it was really shouldn't show wife just fire you and take your fucking
house.
You can't be a basketball coach.
And then where does he go from there?
Like some,
like some fucking know community college,
like adulterous behaviors.
Okay.
No,
no
man.
I think he was ready to retire.
Obviously.
He wanted him to get his guy the job.
So he got his,
the job.
He was like a serial killer that wanted to get caught,
fucking banged her right down there to Hooters.
I want to bring it back to one of the America that I remembered where your side
piece didn't make you lose your job.
It was,
it was handled in house.
You white fucking slapped you,
she took you for everything that you had and then you just slowly drank herself
to death.
But it was none of my business.
Like why should I know that that guy was banging his what?
Oh Bang.
A fucking around on his wife.
He,
I didn't need to know any of that and definitely not a few was going to keep
going to final fours.
Yeah.
Just out of curiosity,
do you think if you have a side piece,
you no longer can explain the triangle offense to incoming freshmen?
Like what is that like?
So many successful people,
they are college kids.
You gotta be real focused,
but some listen,
so many successful fucking people.
The reason why this is successful is because they have laser focus on their
career,
but everything else in their life is a mess.
Their personal life.
A mess.
You sit down to talk to them.
They got a million things on their fucking mind.
So,
because this guy basically doesn't have a perfect life,
Nate Kraig can no longer get excited about the fucking final four.
Thank you.
Over a sidepiece.
I can't say it out loud,
but I'm glad you did bill.
I mean,
I don't know.
I uh,
I just don't like knowing that shit.
I don't know.
I honestly feel that's none of my fucking business.
And I,
I think I actually thinks it brings more pain to his wife now.
Um,
no,
I just,
it's just,
it's none of my fucking business.
Yeah.
And I don't expect anybody that they're going to be perfect,
but if you get in the fucking team to the final four.
Okay.
And you're not banging kids in the shower like they were doing at Penn state.
I mean,
that,
I get,
you're not,
he didn't beat up his wife.
This isn't what you wanted to talk about.
I mean,
I'm just saying,
hey,
he fucked around.
I loved them.
Bo Ryan,
Bo Ryan Hall of fame.
Bobo had a little Ho Ho on the side.
Huh.
And that was the best thing that ever happened in Wisconsin basketball.
And uh,
you know what,
um,
if you had to build a defense football,
how would I know?
I,
we're doing,
let's say like,
listen,
you're on,
I,
I'd make sure I had a male judge and I'd be like,
you know,
you don't get to choose the Cha.
This is Wisconsin.
This is a fly over state.
You know,
you guys can't even read out there.
You guys gave fucking read out there.
I'll use you make fucking cheese.
I'm sure you in Wisconsin to go to pick your judge.
I'm going to my judge,
just let me live this.
Meet your judges
and Hazard County.
So I pick a fucking,
that's a dukes of hazard,
uh,
reference for all younger people.
So I'd pick a male judge,
right?
And I would just be like,
look,
your honor,
can I approach the bench is too many broads in here and I don't want them to
hear this,
right?
This is my fantasy court.
So he come walking up and say,
listen,
you're a successful guy.
Right?
Okay.
Now H
hasn't you?
Wife always made sure that you fucking,
you know,
she always knock,
shut down a little bit.
Just see,
you feel like you don't get too big for your Britches,
no matter what you achieve.
She's always kind of just knocking you down a little bit just to make sure you
know,
judge,
nobody knows better than you.
The effort,
these Yak,
that successes.
I wasn't going that route.
I was going the route that she's just fucking,
you know,
she's still running the shit.
Like the more successful you get,
the more they're going to knock you down.
So there's still run and shit around the house.
So then what happens is is you don't fit.
He does.
It's over there.
Okay.
This guys go to the final four,
like three fucking years in a row.
Okay?
I don't need to tell you that you're living in this state that you got to,
you got to fucking badge your pin right and your rope.
Okay.
Probably shouldn't wear that during the trial,
like get a mistrial.
But this guy,
he's,
I am a big badger fan.
Bill,
you made a good point.
The Guy,
he needs a blow job every once in a while.
Sure.
And,
and it makes them relax.
It makes him here,
his team.
Okay.
We're so close right now.
We are so close to getting a fucking title.
You're saying this is for the kids.
It's for the kids.
It's a fucking sidepiece.
Okay.
This is,
this is between him and his wife.
That's all I'm saying.
All right.
Let them settle it.
Okay.
I'm not saying she shouldn't take the house and everything he's got and go fuck
one of his friends.
I'm not saying that,
I'm just saying we are so close to a fucking championship.
And I,
I think I speak for the state of Wisconsin.
When I say you let this Man Keep coaching at your university.
They have been playing good defense lately.
They have been playing,
locked down the fence.
Lockdown,
defense.
Come on.
It'd be nice.
In a perfect world,
you could,
uh,
pick your judges and your sidepiece litigation.
Yeah,
no,
that's just,
yeah,
it's a,
uh,
is,
it's Joe Rogan says this strange times.
It is strange and the strange time,
strange times.
What does being a,
okay,
I saw two people on the Internet talking about how they're sick of being asked
about this thing that they are both talking to each other about on Twitter.
I just wanted to tweet.
Did you two ever consider exchanging cell phone numbers?
What are you doing anyways?
You're a big baseball fan.
I'm a moderate,
moderate baseball fan.
Yeah.
I remember when the brewers won the first game and you texted me,
he said,
you said build ladies and gentlemen,
your Milwaukee brewers.
They,
they brought,
they brought the fucking lumber out that they thought it was going to happen.
I thought they were gonna make it to the series.
I thought I was gonna.
I thought we were going to have a little Boston,
Milwaukee,
if you could see the way nature down rubbing his fucking face.
Right.
And I just think that his eyes are soft.
They're just soft.
I'm not,
there's no,
but there's only a couple of guys on that team I'm scared of.
I'm pissed that we couldn't beat.
I'm like,
it's gotta be,
I said,
well son,
the guy with a red face,
it's Justin Turner,
Ms Maternity,
Manny Machado's get the best fucking name that should be,
it should have been Ballenger and then the ace to start her.
And I also like,
by way I don't,
as I was saying to you,
I don't think Manny Machado was dirty.
Okay.
Ty Cobb did all of that shit and he's all over the fucking hall of fame.
Right.
Because there wasn't slow mo high def replay to show you when he kicked first
base fishing ankles.
I thought because it was white on white crime back then because it was an all
white league that it was okay if Tim,
if ty Cobb,
uh,
you know,
spike to Ulysses,
whoever the fuck was playing second base back then,
right.
Aberdeen,
whatever the hell his fucking name was.
Right.
I don't think ty Cobb discriminated.
Oh,
that's what I've heard.
Yeah.
You know what it was is probably a white guy who had the audacity to have a
little bit of a Tan that is really fucking weird about like,
you know,
this is like straight up racist in the hall of fame.
Do you know there was,
there was a fucking guy,
and I don't know if this is true or not,
if this is just some scuttlebutt,
but there's literally like a guy in the hall of fame,
uh,
who used to carry a piece from a rope from a lynching is good luck.
Can that be true?
Ooh,
that's a tough one.
That is worse than a side piece.
And Pete rose can't get into the hall of fame because he bet on the fucking
dogs.
It comes the chief,
I like this,
the scuttle butt potential scuttle butt disclaimer,
all because everything,
cause all I do,
the only research I do is I talked to somebody in a bar or I search it on the
Internet and I click on the first thing and whatever it says like I was making,
you know,
sort of in a way like a,
was it Kate Upton?
She was chime in and on the Houston red sox series.
So I'm sitting there going,
oh,
according to Kate Upton,
which was funny to me.
And then I was like,
wow,
isn't that cool?
She's that beautiful and she's down into baseball and somebody find brothers,
hey,
fuck head,
she's married to Justin Verlander.
She's carrying his kid right now.
It's like,
now it makes sense now.
It makes sense.
Okay,
I get it,
but why does it need to make sense to me?
Yeah.
Why?
Why am I mansplaining?
Yeah.
The only thing on my own part or anything wrong with that was the research.
The discovery.
Well,
I feel like I'm a victim of like the intellect that I was blessed with.
So I'm the victim.
I can't help it if people are going to lie and then I'm going to read or maybe
they tell the truth and I don't read it.
I think somewhere in there,
in this current climate,
I could somehow become a victim there.
It's the only true victim hood is not taking responsibility for your own fucking
actions.
Correct?
Yes.
Yeah.
Or just,
uh,
just being expected to research what it is you're having an opinion on.
I have a Wisconsin question for you.
Go ahead.
You grew up there,
right?
Madison,
Wisconsin,
smack Dab,
and you could not escape Wisconsin if you want it to.
Like if you were walking on foot,
how long would it take you to get to a great lake or Minnesota?
[inaudible] couple of days.
It would take me a full,
it would take me,
yeah,
I'd say one,
one 24 hour period on 24 period.
All right.
In the summer of course.
Um,
okay,
so I want to know during the winter,
I want to know how you got out of there,
out of the great state of Wisconsin with that becoming a serial killer,
because that is kind of on the low that if you guys weren't so good at making
cheese,
right?
Yeah.
Then you didn't have the packers.
Yeah,
that'd be a lie.
If you remove those two,
no,
no knives in,
that'd be more,
I'm just saying like that really would be,
you'd have to steer into that and that would have to be your calling card to
basically visit all of these people's houses.
He had Jeffrey Dahmer.
You had the fucking,
the guy who basically they've made like nine different serial killer movies just
based off of everything that he did.
They couldn't fit it all into one script and talking about Ed Gen Ed gain,
ed gain.
He was Hannibal Lecter.
He was the Texas chainsaw massacre guys too.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Texas might get mad at that.
Hey,
don't be taking our fucking Sarah Killers.
They're liberal.
Fucking snowflake.
Fucking scared of driving.
Freckled Kahn.
I'm the only guy I know.
Defense serial killers.
I'm the only guy I know
ever been asked or that we were on the road and we just thought that was the
funniest thing ever.
So redneck shit shit-talking all started up yet.
I'm the only,
I think I heard some guy on the,
on the plane or something.
Say it.
It's just such a ridiculous way to brag about yourself.
You're the only guy I ever know.
I'm only guy I know I have.
No,
I'm the only guy I've ever met.
I'm only guy I ever met with a pan.
Terra bathrobe.
Yeah,
Dude.
We did that for hours.
Where will we drive was at that time we did that Gig in Winnipeg.
We drove all the way up to fucking sad.
Good too.
That was a different time,
I think,
but we still had a southern accent on that for some reason.
I don't know why we didn't go Canadian.
It's just so fun to do the southern accent.
Oh,
you do with a good Canadian.
This little,
sorry.
Oh,
we're going up to Saskatoon w that was a fun drive.
That was so flat.
That's the flat earth I've ever seen in my life.
Yeah,
well that's where they farm out that way and I mean,
dude,
it was so flat that you could see the earth rounding down.
Yeah.
Now,
and you could actually see the northern lights disappear over the flat horizon
up there.
Man.
I know that they farmed there as I read Bonnie Mcfarlane's book and her dad for
some reason went to like Alberta,
which is all rocky and you want to either have like cattle or drill for oil and
for whatever reason he was like,
fuck this,
I'm going to try to farm here and just made their life,
I guess a much more difficult than it needed to be,
which is why she's now a comedian.
I imagined that was your line in Winnipeg was just cause flying into that city.
I mean it's just nothing with Oh yeah.
Nothing around it.
And you're like,
I've never felt so safe landing could've landed anyway anywhere.
A lot of stuff.
Oh yeah.
Shut your eyes and just auto rotate to you.
Felt you.
Skids touched the ground.
It's going to be level still running.
Landing.
Um,
so anyways,
let's talk about your album.
Where uh,
where did you tape this soon to be deemed masterpiece.
Oh,
the masterpiece happened at a dynasty typewriter.
It's a new spot.
It's at the Hayward.
I'm the only guy I ever met,
recorded an album of the dynasty typewriter.
Couldn't tap.
We'll sit Sandler did it.
Uh,
has part of his special there.
Who's new?
A special,
oh I got to see that.
That just came out on the 23rd.
It's great.
There's some of some of that is shot there.
Um,
but I am,
I am the only guy I ever met did album at the dynasty type writer.
And you made a say day?
Uh,
yeah.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
No I didn't.
I mean it's a,
it's a great place and I'm putting my next one out on laser disk,
laser disk.
I just want the true fans to fucking get it.
Why is my phone on making all that noise?
Um,
uh,
what did I do now?
Oh my headphones are working perfect.
And then I had the audacity to touch something.
Can you still hear me Nate?
Cause I can hear myself.
I can hear yourself loud and clear.
Oh wait a second.
Is this going to come through?
Oh,
guess who just got tickets?
Where are you going to go see bill ads?
Pr.
I'm going to go to the fucking red sox.
Atta a boy.
Go support your team.
Go to game.
Go to game three or four cause they ain't going to be no game.
Five buddy.
Okay.
Oh,
would you look at that?
Oh my God.
That's awesome.
That is awesome.
Oh,
okay.
Billy's in the game again.
Gonna sit in the bleachers.
I'm setting up top,
but the real people I need to be down.
Swing me downstairs talking to Jane Fonda.
Jane.
Honestly,
how many games did you watch this year?
Hanging out with Paula Abdul and in the dugout club.
You Rick cold hearted snake.
Is that when she's saying I had the biggest fucking crush on her?
There was so many fucking hot chicks in the late fucking a uh,
there was a chick,
uh,
what was her name?
Can't remember any of them.
Samantha Fox.
Yeah.
Fucking uh,
uh,
the one you just said,
Paula Abdul who was the one in um,
ah,
cadavers hush from labyrinth and she was in requiem for a dream.
The,
she's got brown hair,
goddammit.
Go.
Any weaver?
No,
I don't know.
I'm that Sigourney weaver,
but that was at Tyler.
Yeah,
Jane Fonda.
I'll think about it.
Yeah.
Paula Abdul met her at the dugout club.
You did still good looking,
right?
Yeah.
She's Paula Abdul.
She's great.
Didn't not visible,
but you guys are judge her work and not the way she looks.
Opposites attract.
Uh Huh.
Could you stop being attracted?
Get the up?
Oh yes.
Attract.
That's right.
Oh yeah.
This does fold,
but you take two steps back.
You know what?
You know when the album was over,
when one does that,
that's what we should be talking about was this stupid video she made with the
cat and the had the animated cat,
which was supposed to be like,
uh,
that's when I was being like,
all right.
I think they're trying to get too many hits off this album.
That was opposites attract.
I think that was the video for that.
Oh,
was it?
I think so.
So easy to write a fuckin hit sign back down,
right?
Bump,
bump,
bump out up.
Bobo.
I don't think it's going to be harder bulls.
It's more competitive.
Boat Boat,
boat.
Obu,
back to my album bell.
Yeah.
Dynasty type Craig Bob Bode of Scott,
an album on the internet and blue.
Tammy.
Nate,
how did you come up?
Sorry.
I feel like I'm driving across country with you right now.
You're just giddy cause you got tickets to the world series.
I'm also giddy because I had that operation men over 50 have and I find out I'm
not going to fucking die ass cancer.
I'd fucking did that yesterday.
What did you get put in your butthole?
And I had,
as I kept saying to Nia,
I go two days down,
I go Jacques Cousteau up the ass hole.
That's what I kept calling it.
I add you get a colonoscopy.
Yeah.
So this is just a procedure.
It's a procedure.
They just sneak that camera up in.
Yeah,
dude,
it's the easiest thing.
They meet the neighbors.
You know what the hardest fucking thing is just for everybody out there,
right.
The hardest fucking thing is first of all,
as a guy to actually go to the doctor,
you know,
I'm a typical guy,
he should go and say I'm fun.
Right?
So,
um,
they just scare the shit out of you,
if no pun intended about this thing,
because I think the colonoscopy is a bit of a scam because it used to be you got
to get it when you're over 50.
Then it became 45 now it's 40 and it's like every 10 years now the sand to be
five now the Santa Fe three to five,
I think they got everything,
but now that every guy feels like it's okay to go in there,
it doesn't mean that you're a little fucking on the fence.
You know,
guys are so fucking homophobic.
I ain't get no fucking procedure.
Hicham go with just fucking fake currently age.
Right.
And then you die like Vince Lombardi.
That's why he died.
He was like,
they ain't putting that fucking thing up.
Me.
Granted it was also the late 1960s they just would have stuck their head in
there and be like,
Yep.
It's like you're going to die.
Camera was way bigger back then,
but way bigger.
Is it one of those old fucking,
what are the silent film thing as a crank on this guy with a crank literally
inside your body.
And so he took a picture.
It was that explosion with the fucking Chink,
Chink,
Chink.
Then when they took the picture and there was an explosion for the flesh,
they had to stick that in your two.
We got to talk coach.
Yeah.
So anyways,
the hardest thing was,
uh,
the stuff you have to drink is just kind of,
it's like the best tasting medicine.
It still tastes medicine.
And then you just sort of like,
you know,
you can't eat for a day,
but then when you go there,
it's just you've,
they go,
okay,
here we go.
Here's the fucking anesthesia.
And they put it on.
Yeah.
And then you're,
you're,
you're out.
You're out.
You're out for this year out.
Ooh,
wee.
I didn't know it was like,
yeah,
a lot of trust.
There's a lot of trust.
You're,
and then all of a sudden,
like a second later,
somebody goes,
all right,
you're good.
You're like,
that's it.
That's,
it sounds like a UFO abduction now because that's,
you know,
I willfully went there,
I wasn't walking out into a field of corn pass Ed Jean's house.
So if there's anybody out there of a certain age,
like it's,
it's,
it's easy.
I'm only guy I ever met senior Ufo at target
and I was,
you only got to see,
um,
yeah.
So I'm also giddy about that cause I'm on the other side of it.
Next month I'm getting my heart checked out.
This is all being an old debt,
getting the heart checked out during the stress test.
And then I'm actually for the first time I life going to have like a fucking
doctor where I'll go get a physical every year.
Hold up now are you a,
you walking on your tiptoes today?
I a few on there buddy.
You mean?
Oh,
I have no idea that a group of men were looking at my ass yesterday.
No clue whatsoever.
I,
you know what I mean?
It was sort of probably the same feeling like if you got abducted by aliens,
but the next day you kind of know something went down.
But you don't really remember it.
And it's difficult to relate to other human beings,
but that only lasts for a couple of hours.
Such your doctor,
essentially the world series tickets,
Phil.
Yeah.
Like,
Hey,
fill this.
Never happened.
This never happened.
No,
I am.
I'm,
I'm thrilled so I don't have to go back.
They said for another three to five years and it's just like,
all right,
so then,
but then what's good dude?
It's like back in the day,
remember he got the fucking AIDS test,
right.
And it was just like the first time you got it,
this was every fucking check you'd ever fucking bandwidth and then it's nervous.
Yeah.
And then the next time he got tests and it's just the last three years,
you know,
so it's going to be the same way that I,
I went to Mcdonald's a couple of times.
I've been eating plenty.
I mean,
eating plenty of fucking Bali or whatever the hell are you supposed to be doing.
I've been doing all right though.
But you know,
so I'm,
you know what's funny though is it's still nerve wracking anytime you go to,
I mean,
you know,
that's the,
I'm engaged in.
Awesome.
Good to go.
But to go in and get tested this screenings even.
Oh yeah.
I can't remember the first.
You remember the first yes.
Test you ever.
Yes.
And I had the coolest,
I have the coolest fucking doctor ever to look on your feet.
I was sitting there and he knew I was fine.
He came walking out and he was just going to come on back.
You find,
you find,
don't worry.
Come on back.
I was like,
thank God he didn't do the scared straight fucking thing where he had me walk
all the way back.
Okay,
we got your results and you know,
look behind door number two.
He just saw it.
He says,
dude,
you're fine.
You're fine.
It's like,
all right,
thanks.
Let me know that you came out the gate.
Yeah,
buddy.
Yeah.
And uh,
uh,
so that was,
so,
now that I got that out of the way,
so I'm might Goldberg got after it.
I'm going to g uh,
I didn't really get after it,
but I went after I went in the wrong areas of society and fucking,
uh,
you know,
I was that guy,
I was standing up during battle.
I shouldn't have done that,
you know,
I should have protected myself a little better.
But that was the young me.
Yeah,
that was a man.
Like I grew up in the 80,
so I,
I didn't,
I didn't know any,
he jumped a fence at that point.
You know,
it wasn't a lot of information out there.
Do you know what I'm talking about at all?
You're a kid from the 90s right?
Yeah.
I grew up with like fucking insane.
You're jumped the fence is a interesting saying that I haven't used [inaudible]
and backstreet boys or the beginning.
They were like,
if it's as long as you,
if it was initially considered a gay disease and people who were shooting
heroin,
I remember that.
So there was all these homophobic jokes about it and all of this stuff about
junkies or that type of stuff.
And then who was,
I was probably Magic Johnson and then every was like,
oh well he kiss fucking Isaiah and the Gi guy old fucking know about that.
It's like,
well they do that in France all the fucking time.
Nobody's bagging more women than those guys.
So,
uh,
that,
that was the thing.
Then all of a sudden it had gone into the whole,
you know,
I,
I dunno,
I dunno.
I don't pay attention to stuff.
That's when you,
uh,
you got tested with the week after Magic's press conference?
No,
I got tested,
uh,
mid nineties.
Mid Nineties.
I did.
And I,
I was in a relationship and she's like,
yeah,
we should both get tested.
I was just like,
yeah,
let's do that.
I'm pretty savvy with all the time.
All the time.
No,
but I remember too,
I came out,
I was,
you know,
had nothing clean bill of health and I was just,
I was site was fucking site,
you know,
you got lucky.
Yeah.
You got lucky.
Got Derrick Jordan three pom pom pom pom pom.
Oh,
sorry,
that was loverboy.
Um,
that's funny.
Like they should guess.
Like when you get tests for that,
it would be like,
all right,
what bands were you listening to in high school?
I was listening to loving boy.
All right,
dude,
you might want to sit out for this.
But anyway,
so I'm a,
I'm so I,
this is some weird way that I'm promoting your album.
And also I listened to rush so I was pretty clear that was in the clear,
you know,
I heard a rush song the other day that I actually,
uh,
I hadn't heard in a long time.
I really fun.
I man,
it's a great song.
I work in man.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
No,
no,
no.
Oh,
the luck gay.
So I like it here.
Loverboy I'm damaged some.
That's one hell of a mash up.
Do you know how many times I heard pour some sugar on me in the summer of
[inaudible] 88.
I listened to it a lot.
That was the hot video that summer MTV showed music.
I remember as a kid,
I was a little kid.
Look,
Mommy's playing the trumps with one end.
I thought it was cool.
I think it's really cool that they didn't fire that guy.
They stood by him.
Yeah.
There's people,
all they do is meth and they're out of the fucking banned.
That guy lost an arm and they're still like,
all right,
all right.
Learn how to play with your fate too.
I mean,
they just like,
talk about friends.
I mean,
you got to thank,
if you lose a f,
I mean if a guitar's lost the armies out,
he's out.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you can.
He can.
He can stand on the stage,
but he's,
they're not going to trust him with any solos.
It's a rough one arm with no arms.
Who plays a mean guitar?
I've seen that somewhere.
They'll see me as a CSE slide for his big toe.
He uses a spoon.
There was somebody I saw,
I had like a fucking spoon in his mouth or something like this.
I like whenever I see those fucking things like,
uh,
I'm always amazed by it.
And then also I feel like I'm at Coney Island without paying the fee.
There's always like an element of guilt to this.
Like,
why am I watching this fucking person?
You know,
like this is uh,
you know,
spoon man,
his phone man playing a strong without my hands.
My feet
make me feel guilty for watching you.
Oh yeah.
Oh Man,
I'm sorry.
You know,
we wait,
wait,
what we're basically doing is we're just recreating what we do when we're in the
fucking car
as we're driving up to Saskatoon.
Remember when we were in Winnipeg and we,
we thought they were both pulling us cause we said we're going to Saks discuss
tune.
They kept just kept people in the upper deck just kept going to food.
I thought they were bowing meals.
Just like those are good people up there.
They are good people.
You are sold man.
I was ready to move.
You ready to move?
Find your wife settled down.
Tune tonight.
Get yourself a little farm.
All those creepy serial killer fucking tools that you have no questions in ship.
There you go.
That's right.
One side on the,
is Trump going to make it better?
One side and the uh,
I dunno.
Whatever.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Free ice.
Is that what you get up there?
Just those fucking tons of free ice.
Yeah.
The ice time up there is ridiculous.
It's all 14 months a year.
Oh No,
no.
I was in Ottawa.
I was looking,
I go,
what's up at that rank?
They go,
oh,
if you want to skate around you can,
oh sure.
Did you bring your boots?
Yeah,
they just had an outdoor rink.
There's some woman out there figure skating during like lunch hour.
And then I'm seeing this little kid,
the mother's like teaching them how to like crossover and shit like that.
And I was just like,
this is why we went at the amateur level,
the gold metal,
but not the pro level because they're amateurs are already in the pros.
And that's,
I think that's,
that's my theory why we always win the amateur one,
but we don't,
the juniors,
sorry,
we don't win the,
uh,
the pros,
it's all that free ice.
We're pretty good despite,
despite the fact that we focus on every other major sport first.
I ain't,
you know,
some,
that's a good point.
Despite the fact that I think that the tipping point was when roller blading was
as popular as it was.
I and then roller hockey started getting going.
I thought then we were going to be able to compete with them and then all of a
sudden one homophobic joke.
Different game.
One homophobic.
Joking.
Oh,
it isn't though.
It's the same level of tenacity.
No,
it is not.
It's a slower day.
Craig,
if you're going to try and tell me that roller hockey is slower than ice hockey,
I'm going to end this podcast right now.
That's an easy,
if you're going to give me that,
I'm going to,
I'm going to run with that all day.
You play hockey,
right?
Man,
I'm the only guy I ever met.
You played a high school?
Yeah,
I played high school hockey.
And uh,
how would,
how would you describe your game average below average?
I started kind of late,
but were you,
uh,
was there a main street t game?
No,
I'd definitely like to,
I liked to,
uh,
play physical.
You Physical Guy?
I would.
I would,
I would get the crap knocked out of me,
but I would also,
I would also,
well,
you're not a small guy where you just said your wiring back then here,
you know,
I wasn't,
do you have a temper?
Did your ears turn red when somebody checked you?
Like what half we wanted to hurt somebody if you know it was full of full
contact.
Hockey is the best.
I just haven't played in a long time.
What's the warrants shoulder pads in 20 years,
what's the best you ever got?
Somebody?
Oh my God.
I don't know if you see somebody coming across the middle with their head down.
I mean you can really,
did they have to leave the ice?
Uh,
I don't think I ever heard anybody.
Um,
do you feel bad at all?
No,
I did not ever hurt anybody.
No.
I never felt bad.
Never ever,
ever.
I,
that was,
that's like illegal in hockey.
Like if you actually feel bad,
yeah,
you can't,
it's not for you.
They make you walk out.
That's when you put your own jobs.
That's you at your rollerblades
start taking wide turns out there.
Hey,
let me tell you something.
I'd like to see somebody set up those cones away.
Those kids do in the park and do those little fucking backwards.
A little s turns.
Yeah,
go get some.
Go get them his kids sounds kits.
Yeah,
put it on your little booty shorts.
Come back down backwards.
I don't know.
I we started to,
it was little more manly to roller blade.
I mean it gets cause it's so acceptable to play ice hockey.
You know what I mean?
I thought it took a real man.
Somebody who's really comfortable with themselves,
comfortable to skate backwards in a park.
You know with your short shorts on going around in and out of those fucking
orange cones.
I had a little combs to,
didn't want to come speak to big.
No,
no,
no.
You know you get the little cones cause,
cause otherwise people think,
you know,
maybe think more of you if you have a regular sized construction cone cause
you're getting even more difficult more.
Do you know what it was used for?
Other things that could be confused for like real man activities.
I know what it is.
What it is is the cone would be so high and he had a hunch down that though your
ball bag would be hitting him because your crotch stays right over the fucking
coats.
Yeah,
cause you're so comfortable in who you are.
That's right.
That's you're the kind of guy with a big low hanging ball sack that you might
get that might nick,
one of those tall regular sized cones.
You got to have low cones.
You think it hurts to fall on the ice,
fall on the asphalt.
Okay.
If
you're man enough to rollerblade in the park with short cones and Spandex,
then you got a ball bag that hangs low enough for you to maybe protect
from what he's saying
from a taller cone.
I'm,
I'm siding with the roller blade is here.
I'm agreement.
I'm just say I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not arguing with your point that it takes a real man to go out in the park,
set up cones and rolling.
Secure enough with yourself to,
you might never be bill.
I'm not go roller.
I'm not gonna.
I'm not gonna lie.
I have limitations.
Hey,
I have to to promote,
uh,
something.
Aside from your album preferred customer,
what are you selling this week,
Bill?
I'm selling F is for family.
Season three is coming out on Netflix on November 29th.
Next month.
Um,
it will be a joyous occasion and I think this is our strongest season.
I'm talking a little shit here,
man.
All right.
You understand what I'm doing here.
I'm saying that this is the best work we've done and I challenge you to watch
all 10 episodes.
So I get credit for the ratings before you decide.
Then I sneak.
Hey,
here's something else.
You're on a,
you're on a show maniac also on Netflix,
buddy by the great Jonah Hill.
Huge fan of Jonah Hill.
You only like Jonah Hill when he,
when he promotes something,
if someone gives him shit,
he tells him to go fuck themselves.
I don't know why more celebrities don't do that.
There's always these little nitpick fucking cunty journalists coming at him.
It's just like,
wow,
why don't you just say go fuck yourself?
He does not say he does it all the time.
Not trying to like put it out there that he's like that,
but there was some guy just,
he was harping on him about his fucking weight,
knowing that he was sensitive about it.
You just said,
you know what?
Fuck you fucking,
you just ah,
I wanted to,
I wanted to him to the punch that guy so bad,
you know,
take the lawsuit,
take the little,
can't make them all honest.
Um,
and then there's another thing,
a buddy of mine,
Johnny Hickey in a,
another Boston guy.
He so Boston,
he calls you up.
You're like,
what's up?
Dot.
Yeah.
He's like that level of Boston.
All right.
He's got a movie called the habit that's coming out and there's a premiere
Tuesday,
October 30th in Redding,
Massachusetts.
All right.
Jordan's IMEX Tuesday,
October 30th,
Jordan's uh,
imax.
It's a horror movie.
The habit,
um,
directed Johnny Hickey director,
Johnny Hickey.
Um,
and protect.
It's,
you can go to uh,
oh my God.
The habit premier.
All right.
Is that what it is?
Tickets,
bit.
Dot.
L y slash that habit premiere.
Goddamn I am.
My eyes are just fucking going.
I hope I said that right.
Um,
anyway,
just look up the habit.
Jordan's,
Imax,
Redding,
Massachusetts.
October 30th premiere.
You can and you'll able to find it.
Um,
anyways,
so,
so what else,
Nate,
what else can we talk about?
How much time have we done here?
Your Vision's a little blurry because they crawled up inside you with a,
with a crank crank.
Wayne,
you know,
I would like,
I would like to think that you'd have a little more fucking empathy for me.
Oh,
Bill,
I'm just trying,
I'm trying to make excuses for your poor vision.
Trying to remind everybody what you've been through.
What I've been through.
I'm the victim here.
Yeah.
Told you literally take a nap.
You wake up and the guy's like,
all right,
you're all good and you all feel nothing.
You're all good.
It's,
they got it.
It's a cameras are getting smaller.
The cameras are getting smaller and smaller every year.
You know something that's actually a good point.
Like,
why didn't I,
yeah,
it's not,
it's good that you waited.
I waited till the cameras was small enough.
I'm doing the same thing with hair plugs.
I'm just waiting till they just fucking,
you just throw some fertilizer on your fucking head.
I'm not doing this shit vacuum and stuff out and maybe,
or maybe not.
I'm waiting for when it's 100%.
What are they vacuum?
Well,
they used to take like a slice out of the back.
They'd cut like a fucking,
like a strip,
by the way.
Dude.
You have,
you have the hair I had when I was in like fucking third grade.
He fucking another reason to download preferred customer by Nate Kraig instant
classic,
um,
and watch maniac,
maniac created by Patrick,
some of the Great Jonah Hill.
Jonah Hill,
Emma standed.
Jonah Hill never tells anybody to go fuck themselves unless they deserve it.
It's,
that's right.
Oh,
I love Jonah Hill.
Um,
Oscar nominated John Hill.
I heard him.
I know Howard stern today.
He's got some film coming out too that I'm going to go see.
Yeah,
the eighties or something.
No,
it's about the nineties.
the 90s.
Yeah,
that sounds,
yeah,
I'm going to see that too.
Um,
anyways,
so I got to do what they used to cut a fucking strip out of the back of your
head.
Right.
And then they'd,
it was fucking creepy.
Then they take that,
then they'd sell your head back together.
They take like an eighth of an inch out and then somehow strip.
Yeah,
just that strip they were able to see you like how are you getting,
there's not enough like that hair only covered that amount of your head.
This is going to cover the whole top of your head.
I don't know how they did it.
It's kind of like when they see the room fat,
he's tricking the rest of your scalp and the growing hair.
Well these,
the ones in the back,
I guess they're good for life.
I don't get it.
But like as far as I look at it,
it's like now you're sticking it into the fucking no man's land.
The DMZ.
Right.
Like,
like this is like,
I feel like back here is like,
you know,
you're in the United States of America and then like here you just went to
Baghdad.
Middle of yeah.
Yeah.
Toba,
you might see some fucking action,
right?
You're out on patrol,
you're on point.
So,
um,
the uh,
I dunno sent out someone's trying to claim now like that stem cell shit.
You know,
cause like you fucking shoot it in like Rogan's over like wrote Rogan is like
my,
cause I don't have a real doctor Joe Rogan and his podcast,
the Great Joe Rogan.
Yeah,
he does research.
He actually is a very,
very well read guy.
Like he really does research and I'm lazy,
so I just wait to hear what Joe Rogan says.
And I'm like,
oh,
fucking kettlebells,
man kettle and the way to go of fucking uh,
he's just achieved so much.
The guy was a fucking national champion.
Tyco,
you ever seen his spinning fucking he'll kick.
You ever seen that thing?
Oh my God,
Dude.
You'd have to learn how to speak again if you lived it is fucking ridiculous.
Okay.
Crush that.
Booked a sitcom.
Crush that,
uh,
fucking did a game show,
crushed it as fucking host.
Uh,
crushed it as a comic.
Gets into podcasting.
Biggest fucking podcast.
I mean,
just why wouldn't he know about stem cells?
Sure.
He,
he,
he's a renaissance man.
Fucking now his podcasts,
your doctor,
he hunts,
right?
Kills Elk.
You know,
it doesn't kill him.
He uses the whole thing.
You go over there,
it gives you like fucking elk meat.
So anyways,
he's career.
I would love,
I mean imagine being able to call,
you know,
if you got to call your favorite sport.
Oh yeah.
That's so fun.
No,
and then the,
also the fact that that's as far as like having the best guy fight the best guy,
best woman fight.
The best woman is far is,
is that goes that m m m m.
A.
H.
That's what I feel is what killed boxing was just those guys duck and people for
years and years and years.
And then it's like his,
this is the IBF heavyweight champion.
This is the WBC is the WBA.
Like back in the day when I was a kid,
there was one world champion.
And you had to beat that fucking guy to win.
They weren't like three of them and then somebody is trying to unify the fucking
title.
They became like those fucking superhero movies like after awhile.
It's just like I did.
These two guys exist at the same time.
How are they driving down the street together?
Who's a good guy?
He's a bad guy,
right?
I don't know.
I never really watched the superhero.
I'll still watch boxing now.
I don't know why I still,
I love boxing,
but it's,
it is obnoxious that they can somehow,
can you imagine if if,
if Mayweather and Pacquiao fought when they should have fought and they just had
fucking two or three classics may whether woulda knocked him out three times,
not.
Do you think he had that power?
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't mind.
I don't know enough about it.
I don't either,
but I'm out of my wheelhouse
aside from early Tyson and maybe Roy Jones for a year or two.
He's the best box or I've ever watched.
I mean,
yeah,
you can't hit the guy.
He can't hit the guy and his left that left comes just real heavy.
Yeah.
I think he would have knocked out my Manny Pacquiao a couple times for sure.
If they had a fight.
Well we ain't.
They should father [inaudible] how do you think he would have done?
Was he like,
was he in middle middleweight?
What was he?
I don't know.
Well,
if he was in that division with Hagler,
Hearns,
Leonard and Duran and all of them took a loss because all four of those guys
were around at the same time.
Now I don't know enough about boxing,
like I'm going to go out on a limb here and say there wasn't that level of
talent is division.
So taking that guy back in time,
because I had his big argument one time with Versie about this,
where he verse,
he said he would have beat all four of those guys.
I'm like,
all four of those guys couldn't even beat each other.
How much weight does he have on this way?
I wish I knew the way class.
Well,
let's just say they were the same way class.
The big thing with Tommy Hearns was he was so fucking tall and could make that
weight.
He was like six feet
total wine.
No,
I think what may,
whether it be any of those guys,
because the difference in from now and then is significant in the training and
the Diet.
No,
no,
but that's not a fair thing.
I'm saying if everybody had the same training the same day they came up in the
same era.
I Dunno.
I didn't watch,
I didn't watch enough any of them,
but I,
I think that a Floyd Mayweather definitely could,
could bang and stand up
guy an antique.
It would be good against any of them.
I just don't know.
If you go for now
foreign,
Oh yeah,
that's tough.
But they should be fighting all of any,
yeah.
There should be no cupcake fights.
Get back to hair plugs.
I don't,
I still can't wrap my head around how some hair follicles are going to trick the
other hair follicles and grown more here.
No,
no,
no.
These ones are just like,
okay,
these ones up here are sensitive.
Right.
That's why it's like these ones back here were raised right.
Like their parents didn't just,
if they fell down they said rub some dirt on it.
They just,
these ones up here were,
I dunno.
I dunno what hat by just everything was not there.
Like the teacher said the kid was a fucking asshole.
The parents blame the teacher rather than looking at the kid.
Those,
those are the,
that's that hair on top he had.
So evidently something that I breezed by quickly on the Internet was claiming
that stem cell is close to whatever you're going to go shoot this shit at the
top and I'll have fucking hair like yours.
Of course.
You know my color though,
right.
So I was joking with my listeners that I am doing this,
I haven't quite announced yet cause we want to announce all the dates.
I have this east,
east Germany,
eastern European tour coming up in January.
And I was saying I'm going to find some Transylvanian doctor and they're going
to fucking shoot my head up.
Right.
And I'm going to be over there long enough and I'm going to come back with like,
like a Farrah Fawcett haircut,
full ginger,
lack Transylvania now
with my yellow eyebrows and my fucking freckles.
Yeah.
I'm going to come back looking like Jaclyn Smith,
the Reddit,
a male version of that,
but jet black hair that said it's going to be,
it's going to be,
and you know,
it's,
I'm going to tell you Nate,
it's going to be weird and it's going to affect our friendship,
but I really only think for about three weeks and you're just accept it because
I'll still be me.
I'll still be telling the same jokes.
I'll still smoke a cigar with,
you know,
it could change it.
You're just going to have,
can change your bill.
In what way?
I don't know.
You know,
send me a full,
full,
beautiful head of flowing black hair.
I'll send,
I get a convertible,
I'll get one of those things.
Like those firsts.
No,
those old willys jeeps right where you can put the windshield down so I can just
have the hair blowing the whole fucking time.
Well,
she see burst hair.
He's not sleeping.
He's driving a hearse now
on the vampire route.
Yeah.
And be fucking all will be all gray.
Be like that.
I'll look like a lost boy.
I'll be a redheaded fucking lost boy.
I got to learn how to say that in,
in Czechoslovakia.
When I walked into the head doctor
and he asked me,
how can I help you?
All right.
I'm just going to be,
I want to,
I want to look like a fucking,
what did I do?
A redheaded lost boy make me look like I've been here for thousands of years.
I don't want that.
Look.
I know what that look,
dude,
if I did that and then I started botox,
do you realize the roles that would open?
I'd have the shiny frozen face,
right?
You'd have to start working at a casino.
You'd have to sign a contract at a casino.
Oh No,
I don't want to go that route.
Um,
anyways,
so I guess,
I guess I'm going to game format fun.
I'm psyched.
Oh by the way,
the all things comedy,
uh,
podcast,
festival is this weekend out there in Arizona.
Want to thank everybody?
I think it starts up tonight.
I'm Paul Versey is out there.
I'm going to be there tomorrow doing a live podcast.
Live.
I live.
I do this shit.
Talking to myself,
live in front of a crowd.
I've only done it one other time and I did it in a,
hey,
maybe I'll talk about getting my colonoscopy.
Where are you going to do this?
Um,
and uh,
what's that?
What's that comedy club there and fucking laughs.
What's the,
what's the one there?
Yuk yuks stand up live in Phoenix knee.
Slappers and Phoenix.
What's it called?
Not the Tempe Improv.
Stand up library and that stand up light.
There you go.
Yep.
That gut busters.
Good posters.
What's it called?
They're a funny bone.
Um,
yeah,
I'm going to be doing that and then we'll be doing a standup show after that.
So,
uh,
NLS,
we'll be doing the goddamn comedy jam.
So I,
I have,
I have to fucking learn how to play a fucking song by then,
man.
Goddamn,
Goddamn.
I do.
I got to get them changes down,
man.
Everybody knows,
When you're the drummer,
you can fuck up as it guitars.
You can fuck up on that fit along,
but you fuck up as a drummer.
Everybody knows it.
Even they don't know it was you.
They know something happened.
I'm the only guy I ever met come learn a fucking song on a fucking southwest
flat fucking Phoenix,
Arizona.
50 minutes.
I'm only guy I ever met took,
took drum lessons on a pontoon boat.
I'm the only guy I've met made drum sticks out of a platypus.
I'm only guy I ever makes his
own
possum bacon.
You can actually bake,
right?
You can actually cook.
Yeah.
I mean it's limited.
My game was through down.
You came to the rose one year.
I thought you,
I thought you threw down.
You made something.
Did you send me a picture?
No,
I've been to your tailgate twice.
I didn't,
I,
I freeloaded both times.
Free loaded my ass off.
Were you here when I fell for like 45 SAS?
I was right there.
That was perfect.
Uh,
sorry.
Sorry.
Yeah.
You wrapped around.
I was losing my balance.
Standing Tent Pole.
You try to hold on to like,
you try to hold onto like a foldout tent.
Like it was like a pillar at like a,
like a shelter.
Oh yeah.
That aluminum thing that you tried to balance on something that
was 15 pounds tops.
I says,
sorry,
like 19 times in a row before I finally went down.
Somehow the things stayed in one place and you kind of wrapped around it.
You fell over a cooler and then slept in a folding
chair for about two hours every year.
I do the power nap.
I knew the power nap.
I remember one year being so hammered that thing,
I was smoking my Cuban cigar before law headed,
finished the entree salads and people were just,
I mean I was
mess.
People were taking all,
they will walk and by Rangers were taking pictures with you like you were like a
,
like a Marlin hanging.
They didn't want to go near me.
I,
I remember looking up at some mothers going by with children just and I,
and I,
I didn't understand.
I thought they used to be looking at me with disgust,
but now that I am a parent,
I know what that look was.
That was,
that was actually how do I prevent my children from doing that,
from becoming that because whoever their parents are,
they failed completely.
Um,
I'm only guy I ever met,
got fans in my sleep.
That's a good one.
That's some shit talk.
I'm the old guy I haven't met.
Can't read out loud.
Does it?
Every fucking weekend.
His podcast I got to do fucking,
uh,
I got to do some fucking,
I got to read some shit here.
What'd you say?
Season three.
November 29th.
November 29 season three.
Yeah.
It was for family,
booboo,
booboo barrier where they are doody or do you do come and watch this shit.
Season three.
All right.
Oh,
hey,
here we go.
Um,
you like advertising,
right?
Nathan?
Love it.
All right,
here we go.
By the way,
November 29th I'll be at Zane.
He's in Saint Charles.
Oh,
you will say,
well,
I remember that run.
Is that the one?
When is that?
When you start,
uh,
you start downtown and then you,
did you do Saint Charles and then Mount Vernon or something?
That one's close,
but the Saint Charles [inaudible] is still open.
I'll be there at 29th,
which was that Illuminati legs sort of like,
first it was like this sort of the middle of nowhere.
Like giant ranch stats.
Pheasant run.
That's the Saint Charles.
Yeah,
it's the reserve.
The rest of the,
it's like a quarter walk to the venue
and you never go outside.
Yeah.
You never go outside.
So it's a real Midwest casino experience.
I love it.
All right.
Does everybody hymns?
It wasn't us.
It was hymns.
Here's a problem.
Oh,
look at this.
66% of men lose their hair by age 35.
Look at that,
Nate.
You're in the top fucking 34% thing is,
is when you start to notice hair loss.
It's too late.
It's easier to keep the hair you have than to replace the hair you've lost.
Is that hairline slowly starting to move backwards?
Any bald spots yet.
How will you feel a year from now if it's business as usual up there?
Why do guys turn to weird solution or do nothing when they can turn to the
medicine?
I was getting slightly offended at this and we can turn a medicine and science.
Uh,
what hymns does is connect you with real doctors and medical grade solutions to
treat hair loss,
well known generic equivalents.
To name brand prescriptions to help you keep your hair.
No snake oil pills or gas station.
Counter supplements.
Prescription solutions backed by science.
No waiting room.
No awkward doctor visits.
Save hours by going to four hymns.com answer a few quick questions.
Doctor will review and can prescribe you products are shipped directly to your
door.
Um,
order now.
My listeners get a trial month of hymns for just $5 today,
right now while supplies last.
See website for full details.
This would cost hundreds if you went to the doctor or a pharmacy.
Go to four
hymns.com/bird.
That's f o,
r h I m
s.com/burr for
hymns.com/bar oh look who's here now,
but it boop boot me undies.
Me undies.
I'm the only guy I ever met.
Doo,
doot,
Doo me undies,
me,
Andy Yanked seem a fucking dick yet.
I'll take it out and shake it.
It you face.
There ain't no meat to one Oklahoma.
Where at a dance.
And I took you.
Sorry.
All right,
me undies.
Uh,
you've heard me obsess over me undies and all the amazing colors and prints they
offer.
But guys,
did you know that me undies also makes the world's most comfortable lounge pants
and t's
will.
Did you with fall finally here?
Yeah,
with global warming and finally got here.
Now is the perfect time to put these cozy essential to the test fall offerings.
The lounge pants are made from the same micro modal modal fabric as their
undies.
Uh,
let me tell you,
you'll be in fall heaven when you cover your entire bottom half with fabrics
that's three times softer than cotton.
Biondi is also loves celebrating the fall season with fun Halloween Prince.
Check out their latest jack-o-lantern print him,
Jacqueline A.
Prince in undies,
socks and bralettes pronounced bralette.
Why don't you help me,
how to say fucking modal.
I'm the only guy I ever met were a Bralette,
didn't get his fucking ass kicked down at the bar.
Uh,
the best part when you join me at the membership,
you can get all this stuff,
lounge pants,
t's under these fucking elk antlers that you didn't shoot,
but take credit for everything me undies makes for less than anyone else.
Special member pricing is just one of the many perks of joining the membership
beyond.
He's has a great offer for my listeners.
Any first time purchasers,
when you purchase any me on these,
you get 15% off and free shipping.
This is a no brainer.
Get 15% off a pair of the most comfortable undies you will ever put on,
um,
to get your 50% off your first pair.
And free shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird that's [inaudible] dot com slash bar oh,
Nate.
Okay.
You don't need hair plugs.
Maybe your balls a nice and soft and whatever the fuck you wearing right now,
but I have a product for you.
Butcher box.
You ever heard of this shit?
No.
Dude,
I'm gonna take,
this is the best pork chop I've ever fucking had delivered right to my door.
Right in my Goddamn skillets.
Seasoned Railey.
You know,
finished it in the oven.
Took it out.
Give it a fucking rosemary fucking butter bath.
Unbelievable.
All right.
What's your box delivers healthy.
100% grass fed and grass finished beef free range.
Organic organic chickens and heritage bread.
Bread,
pork.
Now like you,
you're probably like me.
You'll probably ask me what is heritage bread?
Pork.
This is exactly what I was
was asking.
You know what the fuck this is?
Evidently these are pigs.
Pure pigs.
All right,
that you can trace the bloodline back to Europe.
These were the original snooty pics.
Now like these filthy once that are all fucking mixed here.
This is like sort of like the Klan meats,
pork.
I'm only guy I ever met each royal bacon.
It's royal fucking Bacon,
right from his fucking highnesses Goddamn Lounge.
Um,
do this,
this,
I dunno dude.
This,
it was the greatest fucking pork chop other than I went to a gourmet restaurant
and they really knew what they were doing.
But I'm a comedian and I cook this thing and this thing fucked with that pork
chop.
All right.
Butcher box.
Yes.
Right.
The incredible quality of butcher box meets,
start with the commitment to raising animals humanely and free of antibiotics
and hormones before they murder them.
All right?
Each box comes with at least nine to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals.
Unless you're a fat binge eating fuck,
then you probably just stick your face in it and eat fucking Ramy.
Please try to cook the chicken to all the fatties out there.
Uh,
you can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork,
mixed box,
gender neutral porque.
No,
that's not something.
Custom box.
Antibiotic Hormone fee free butcher box believes in a healthier food system
where everyone has to meets the way nature intended.
Free of antibiotics and hormones that humanely raised on open pastures before
they murder those animals.
Selection.
Butcher box carefully curated the finest selection and cuts.
It makes it a breeze to customize your own delivery.
Build your own box.
They get exactly what you and your family love.
Choose your delivery frequency with the cust.
Customizable subscription recipes are available on butcher box.
Website and videos are available to follow along on butcher box youtube channel.
Um,
for Free Bacon and $20 off your first box,
go to put your box.com/burner enter the Promo Code Bar that's $20 off and Free
Bacon Promo Code Bar.
Um,
oh my God,
dude,
I gotta tell you everything in there is great,
but I am.
I am a big,
big fucking a pork chop guy.
Uh,
to guess what the fucking Terminex guy's come and I got termites in my house.
You got to get a tent put up.
I got it.
I got to get a tent that I can slowly fall around for 45 seconds is I say sorry
and sorry.
So lets,
lets fucking wrap this up here.
Nate,
you one of my favorite people in this fucking business.
You really are buddy.
You really?
Yeah.
You were raised right.
You know your dad made you refinish that fucking basement right yet to get on
your hands and knees and scrub it.
He said the floor wasn't clean enough.
Wire brush.
Why are fucking brush it would again do it again.
Came downstairs.
Yep.
Scrape the house and it's right.
Yup.
You were down there crying and saying how much you hated your dad and he didn't
let you back up to your fucking
good.
Finished it.
Right.
He's a beautiful man.
He is but I'm just saying real,
real Mister Miyagi treatment.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Wax On.
Wax Off.
You have a CD out.
It is called preferred customer.
It's available on iTunes.
I'm going to download it because I support you and everything that you do and a,
and my wife loves you.
You know,
usually she's like,
take those animals out back you.
She actually,
let's in the house
here@natecraig.com.
We love the burst.
All right.
Um,
and with that maniac on Netflix,
I'll be at a go bananas in Cincinnati February 7th through the
10th.
You got it.
Um,
let's see here.
And then,
um,
before we go to the throwback,
we got,
um,
I,
I called into the sports gambling podcast with Shawn Green love shrine.
Ryan Kramer.
These guys know their shit and I'm just showing green.
I'm just the dope on the show.
Um,
you can listen to my picks for the week.
I'm getting more and more house wifey,
like New Orleans versus the Vikings.
Well,
I love Bourbon Street,
so,
and I love drew Brees.
I just think he's a family man.
I'm taking the saints and then we'll have a bonus half hour of a greatest hits
Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Have a great weekend.
You can
[inaudible]
Whoa,
go pray my shotgun.
Oh,
ain't going start shooting
again.
Go Brang me my shot gun.
You know,
I just got to start shooting again.
I'm gonna shoot my woman.
Oh is she fooling around with two mini me?
Bill Burr on the sports gambling podcast is brought to you by my book G.
My book is the leader in online sports.
Folks use the Promo Code Bill bets for a 100% deposit bonus.
Play Wayne and get paid at my bookie dad [inaudible] joining us on the line
courtesy of my bookie Dad Agee Promo Code Bill Bets,
the one and only bill burr.
Bill,
appreciate you calling in and we,
we got you away from the game.
Currently,
right now we're taping during a world series game one right now.
The sacs are up five to three.
How are you feeling?
You don't have me away.
I'm the guy who never feels confident about his team.
I feel like the Dodgers had been in the last couple of years and haven't been
able to get it done.
So they got a lot of experience and all of that.
But uh,
I'm hoping,
you know,
we can come out with a victory here tonight.
You know the usual stuff.
Bill Belicheck I've learned you don't talk trash,
no bulletin board material.
That was always a,
I love that he,
uh,
who is it the patriots receiver that made all those Rex Ryan for choker.
Yeah,
Wes Welker in that press conference where he just kept calling out the rex Ryan
foot fetish video and then Belicheck had to lay the hammer on him and drop him
for a,
I think he made them sit the first quarter.
Yeah,
we lost that game against the jets.
Plus it makes you wonder what,
uh,
Malcolm Butler did before the Superbowl as far as like,
what are you got to do to get sat for the Superbowl?
But I,
I guess we'll never find that.
No,
I think what you're going to have to do is years later you got to be on a golf
course with some,
uh,
old time patriots or whatever.
Someone,
some of,
we'll have a couple too many cores,
lights and someone will tell you what happened eventually.
Yeah.
I liked that.
They've kept it in house.
So
yeah,
he had Belicheck actually did the intro to the world series.
I don't know if you caught that.
Uh,
up top he did the voiceover for kind of like the hype video leading into a
writing voice,
which he's an amazing coach,
but his,
his voice over work kind of monotone there.
I think it's just muscle memory at this point.
Everybody,
everybody who's like on the team says he's actually a funny guy,
but you know,
he's just smart.
Like that's,
that's scrapped it.
Those guys were doing that guy in the Astros who showed a them lighten up.
Was it price or something?
I forget who.
I forget who that was wasn't priced but,
but it was just so,
you know,
when they went back to back to back against them.
So just looking at some game film,
it's just like,
why would you do anything to amp up the other pro?
Because the second you get pissed you're not scared anymore.
It's like,
let him sit there in silence and think about,
I hope I don't screw this up.
You know,
instead you get them all motivated.
It's dumb,
dumb move.
It's the most obvious like same tactic in sport.
Just don't talk,
just don't speak everyone.
Everyone gives Belcher crap up.
What should he say to the media?
Should he tip his hand as a,
as a fan,
you don't want them giving away any the slightest thing,
either motivation or strategy wise.
Why would you ever say anything?
And Sean,
you know,
he probably got into it when he was a younger man because for Lawrence Taylor to
respect bill,
it's bill a check on the level that Lawrence Taylor respects bill Belichick.
He's seen some shit,
right?
Lt got after it pretty hard there.
Yeah.
I think,
uh,
you know,
I have to reason the media hates us is because we,
we always win and the other half is because bill Belicheck makes him so
difficult to do their job.
They like,
like they loved Rex Ryan.
Rex Ryan was a quote machine and it's just like,
he just gave him easy days.
He just,
Hey,
I'm not going up there to kiss his rings.
You know,
we're going to win the Superbowl.
He was like it.
Rex Ryan,
it was like interview when a wrestler during a Promo,
right?
No,
it's cutting a pro.
He was the heel Trump.
I mean if they,
rex Ryan is the football equivalent of Trump.
Exactly.
Yeah.
The article writes itself and Bill Belicheck.
It's just like,
Oh man,
I get now I actually have to watch the game and come up with something smart to
say,
you know,
some sort of analogy rather than just building it around the crazy thing or our
coach said,
yeah,
breaks.
Ryan made everyone's job easier.
All right bill,
let's happen with some of these spreads.
Moving over to the NFL,
kicking things off lines.
Courtesy again from my bookie dad Agee big game here in New Orleans,
head into Minnesota right now.
The Minnesota Vikings.
A one point favorite at home.
Which way you lean in here.
I love drew Brees and I love New Orleans and I like to drink [inaudible] call
with New Orleans
solid combo.
You can't,
you can't beat that Combo.
Yeah.
Yes.
They opt to stay off of Bourbon Street.
I got some places you can y'all ego with the local go.
You don't go to a purpose street.
That's The Times Square of New Orleans.
You had it.
Hey,
hang out with video and need some chicken on a stick and a gas station,
Shawn.
Yeah.
This is,
I mean,
there's a huge revenge angle here,
right?
Oh yeah.
I mean,
New Orleans coming in after what happened to knock them out of the playoffs,
that miracle in Minnesota,
the way they lost that game.
I mean,
they were,
obviously they should have won that game.
Total collapse.
New Orleans coming in on fire,
five and O in their last five.
But more importantly for,
and one against the spread.
This New Orleans team,
I think if they gonna slip up,
it was,
it was going to be against that ravens team.
Right.
But they played well hung in that game.
And this team just seems to it in the NFC right now,
it's just gotta be the saints or the rams.
Right?
I mean they,
they seem like they're really firing on all cylinders.
Yeah.
I'm going to play the regression angle.
Everyone's seeing the CTO and Vikings,
Vikings,
I'm,
I'm gonna.
I'm not gonna they're pros.
I don't think the revenge thing is real.
And I think this Minnesota defense has turned it up of late and uh,
yeah,
everyone's kind of forgotten about that sick home field advantage and I think
it's coming back so well.
New Orleans normally not go on the road,
but I mean it's another dome team.
I think this is a decent spot for him.
Yeah.
All right to that.
I actually,
I don't believe in that.
You know,
the,
the grudge matches anymore unless it happened the same season with the lodge of
free agencies and how much everybody hangs out each of with each other in a
barbecue.
It's not the way it used to be.
Yeah.
Everyone's,
you know,
hanging tag,
you're tagging each other on the gram and shouting each other ad,
especially in the NBA,
the NBA,
it just feels like one big rec league where there's just,
okay,
there's one team that's clearly going to dominate and then everyone else is just
kind of having fun hanging out.
Yeah.
It's like a warehouse playing softball against each other and it's really just
about going out and having some beers,
you know?
Yeah.
They may as well turn the NBA into a beer league league at this point.
Uh,
it's gotten
crazy.
Nobody,
I mean,
what was the last thing you saw on Instagram?
Video of a dunk where there was anybody seriously challenging somebody.
First of all,
you're not even allowed to be in the paint and all these kids know,
Oh man,
I'm going to be on the gram.
So they usually get your head taken off,
but not,
not you.
Just kidding.
I don't know.
It's just completely,
everything is completely different game.
Like,
uh,
did I talk to you guys about that Kansas City Patriots game?
No,
I don't.
I don't think we talked about that,
but uh,
yeah,
that like that right there like that is not football.
Like I that's like watching two people playing a video game with live people
like the fact that that number 10,
I always forget his name,
whatever his name is on cancers.
Tyreek hill,
he's killing you the whole game.
There's a minute or two minutes left,
you know,
that go to him.
Not only does he score,
he ran across the field,
he runs up the side like untouched for like 70 yards.
I get the guys fast,
but no,
she just,
she just ran out there like it was,
you know,
the coach's son and there was something out to a,
nobody touched them on this play then.
It was like a,
make a wish,
a moment,
please let him run down.
Tired until,
as leukemia at juvenile diabetes.
Come on.
And he's living out his dream.
And to the point of that,
how the leagues have gotten soft,
if anyone hasn't listened to Charles Oakley,
discuss this on the Simmons podcast,
he really just keep calls.
He's like,
yeah,
it's a,
you know,
back in my day,
we just fought.
He's like,
when we said we were in a fight,
we fought nowadays,
who knows?
That doesn't mean much,
you know,
like it,
it,
it's,
it's odd.
I know.
Well,
and then,
uh,
and then Tyree hill got the beer poured on him by,
one of the pats fans and that was a disgrace.
That was a,
that was the whole big thing.
And it,
uh,
my buddy actually,
it kind of reminded me of the malice at the palace.
And,
uh,
my buddy actually sent me,
Bill has a great bit about it back in the day when it happened,
about how awesome it was to just see a professional athlete go up into the
stands and beat the shit out of a shitty fan.
It's,
it's really as,
listen,
we're walking the wrong guy.
That was the only thing that sucked was he got,
he didn't get the rug that she knows something I liked.
Everybody was like,
Oh,
real classy patriots fans.
And everybody forgets that the Yankees,
you know,
uh,
through the,
through a beer in a relief pitcher this year when they call bad home run,
uh,
a fan of the,
and so whatever,
whatever the hell happened on that out that play.
I can't remember the New York capers with trash in the red sox and they made
that kid when the Yankees Played Baltimore way back in the day that he reached
over was a basket catch it.
They made that kid a local hero.
Yeah.
Jay is definitely mayor.
Was that his name?
Uh,
and I,
I would say this as a compliment to,
to red sox and even Eagles Fan Philadelphia fans.
There is that element of like,
yeah,
I grew up going to red sox,
Yankees fans and you know,
I saw a dude like fall from love the middle deck to the lower deck.
Like do things got thrown.
Like that's part of the game.
Everything's just Yah.
I mean I know out here it's about bringing knives to the game,
but there's a certain,
there's a certain beauty in like the,
the,
the flying here bottle,
simple beer toss
and the most would be going to gain for the world series last year.
Awesome.
As a red sox fan and I will be dressed like a undercover cop.
I will not have any red sox stuff on.
I just,
I don't still need it.
It's just out here.
It's just not fun.
Made that mistake
I made,
I made that mistake one time.
Wore a don Mattingly who,
you know,
most people,
most people say even if you hate the Yankees,
you like Donny baseball.
Where am my don Mattingly,
a Jersey to the bleachers.
The all you can eat bleachers that at Dodgers stadium,
multiple,
multiple food items thrown at me during the game.
You're going to a place where they have unlimited ammunition.
Ryan,
it was fun.
My favorite thing is when you literally get in threatened bodily harm and curse
that and that and it's by some dude and he's there with like,
he has like three kids under the age of age.
Yes.
Like what are you doing?
What are you teaching these?
These,
these kids.
You turning them into animals and it's just,
it's just how it is out here and it's straight across the board.
Like it isn't like a,
I guess if you sit down in the bleachers,
it's,
I mean in the box seats it's a little bit nicer,
but it's just like,
I don't care.
Like you know,
black,
white,
Latino.
Yeah.
I don't chair.
It's just straight across the board.
These people out here,
we're just like,
no,
we're going to kill you.
It's like,
it's like,
all right,
well that was,
that was a fun first dating.
I guess I'll go down and get a hot dog and sort of meander around the stadium to
get away from you guys.
And I put my hat in my back pocket.
But
it's such a,
it's such a weird dichotomy because you think of La and you don't think of like
passionate sports fans,
but then,
oh yeah,
we'll randomly murder you over a baseball game.
The weird,
weird,
weird.
We're building great stereotype.
I believe sports fans,
right?
Casual.
Somebody in you need to be one.
I almost got into a fight.
Security had to come up,
escort us out and it's a San Diego chargers game.
Uh,
almost got killed in a gun for threatened to be stabbed at an angel's game.
Wow.
By then I'd learned my lesson.
I'm like,
these people are like out of their mind.
Uh,
you know,
and then,
some Celtics Lakers crap.
I was a Celtics Jersey,
Paul Pierce Jersey in the upper deck.
Oh,
mad move bad move you Irish dish.
You Irish Stack Austin.
You chowder?
Hell yeah,
the whole damn thing.
It.
By the time I went to a Raiders patriots game,
I was just like,
I'm just going to wear a black tee shirt.
And uh,
you know,
like,
uh,
I dunno,
ll bean hat or something
that's like Ellen degenerate or something.
I'm going to go to the skate complete.
Completely neutral.
It's a funny,
just rewind and Sean and of course we had our first,
they never in all my years of going to east coast football games,
never saw someone break a beer bottle with the intent to stab another human
being first football game.
We went to San Francisco at the old part.
Yeah.
A Raven's niners game was sitting in traffic trying to leave the game and Bam,
we almost witnessed a murder.
It's just,
it's,
it's much more hardcore.
And the game was a hilariously bad game.
It was 12 to nine.
There was no touchdown scored and maybe that's what got him all work.
Yup.
And would actually doing fans of service,
because this story is not told at all,
you know,
is the eagles through batteries.
It's Santa Claus and blah,
blah,
blah.
Eagles and Philly and Philly and show Austin New York.
Yeah.
Yes,
but no,
you,
you can get killed out here.
We got to cut a PSA.
Hey Listen La,
you think it's a casual sports down but you can get murdered over the wrong
jersey.
All right.
Speaking of La,
the Los Angeles Rams there at home late nine and a half points to the green bay
packers.
Aaron.
Yeah,
right.
Rims.
Just Ram it guys ran that knife into my ribcage.
Cut.
Slice my cheese.
Head Up.
Uh,
I dunno,
a quick sidebar Sean,
but I don't know if you've noticed,
but some of the TV,
the local coverage of the rams.
I think because they
so good.
In the beginning they didn't,
didn't
change anything and some of these guys just don't know football.
It's pretty hilly.
It's the watch,
this shakes.
It's like,
this is nothing like a east coast like postgame show.
These people don't know anything about the game.
They're not even rooting for the team.
Like,
what the fuck is this?
It's a long way off.
But all that being said,
I'll take the rams lay nine and a half.
This team is fire Aaron Rodgers though this is his,
uh,
the biggest underdog.
He's ever like the biggest underdog spread of his entire career bill house a
year.
Are you going to get on that
pack?
Take the package with the point.
Cause Aaron Rogers,
he's one of those guys,
he loves to send kids home crying and the opposing stadium like he gets up
toward,
he plays great on the road.
And uh,
I dunno,
I looked up some numbers on this one.
Package defense isn't that bad?
I don't think,
you know,
I dunno.
I I uh,
oh that's a tough one.
Just all of those points and Aaron Rodgers,
I and his competitive ways.
I would w I'm going with that.
You know what am I am a stand up comedian.
What do I know?
I'm not trying to get stabbed in la because I picked the packers.
I'm sorry
you liked the packers to cover,
but you said the rams away now.
Right?
To clarify if anyone had
yeah,
undo me.
They just have too many weapons there and so does the people in the crowd.
Thank you
Kramer.
Which way you lean in.
Uh,
I mean it,
it's,
it's an awful lot of points for one,
Aaron Rodgers and no matter the deficiencies they might have on defense,
this is,
this is even if they're down,
this is backdoor city.
Aaron,
Roger's not going to be giving up and Sean,
75% of the money on the Los Angeles for him.
They got to lose at some point,
right?
Maybe this is the week,
hypothetically and yeah,
you gotta think that Aaron Rodgers and you don't want to a little brother Jared
Goff.
Imagine Aaron Rodgers.
Like,
I'm not losing to this bitch.
I am not losing to this little bitch.
Well,
golf is a weight.
Golf came from what school?
Cow.
Ow.
So maybe their buddies.
Well,
that's what I'm saying.
I think he's,
I think Aaron Rodgers wants to prove he's the real cow.
QB.
Oh,
little a little revenge gears Rogers older than McNay.
I think he's gotta be cosmic phase like 32 yeah,
that's crazy.
That's really crazy.
All right.
Last game of the slate here in New England patriots face heading into Buffalo,
where right now over my bookie.
Dot.
Agee.
The buffalo bills are a 14 point Monday night home dog dare,
journeymen Derek Anderson starting again.
I love that phrase.
And I also love they would say he signed off the street as if he was just
wandering around.
He's starting at quarterback for the pills.
Lashawn Mccoy looks like he could be out.
Bill,
do you,
uh,
did the Pat's role here or do you,
you think it's close enough that the bills are worth the taking a shot with the
points?
I hate 14 points with the division rivalry and you're on the road and also the
bills are so schizo phrenic this year.
This is,
this is one of these,
each one of these trap games,
Bill Suck right them all.
They won 27 nothing against the Vikings and the next week they get killed or
they up 27.
Nothing is biking.
I,
uh,
I'm gonna say,
um,
I would,
I would take the bills into points simply watching last week when we played the
damn bears and we had them,
we should have put him away,
should have driven down the damn oh my God.
And kicked the field goal.
Been up by,
by,
by three scores instead we ended up,
you know,
when we came within a half a yard of going into overtime,
that was a crazy hail Mary to get to the one yard line.
Oh Man.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And that's that whole thing like you stick your stick a wide receiver down
there.
He's not going to try to knock it down.
He's gonna try to catch it.
That guy that wasn't Gordon,
the guy we got from Cleveland and he did not even try to do,
what did he,
he,
he was,
he was a,
he was out of his element.
Uh,
they might want to run that play with him a couple of times.
So I think the Patriots are going to win,
but I don't,
I don't numbers too big there.
I will say in the end they go into the prevent and it screws over the gamblers.
Who uh,
who checked the Patriots with 14
Kramer,
I mentioned Sean night,
first of all,
97% of the money coming in in the page early,
but it will be money night.
This bills,
this bills fan base will have nothing.
This is the,
this is a super super bowl,
right?
There'll be breaking tables.
The price will be out there breaking tables with them.
There's,
there's,
there's no doubt of that.
And Buffalo strength is their past defense.
So I could see the way they play,
the way Mcdermott sits in kind of that soft coverage that a while Brady might
pick them apart,
the receivers are going to take hits.
Sean,
it's,
it's a low of 38 that night.
So yeah,
of course you're taking 14 right?
Even with
Derek Anderson Walking,
what could go wrong?
What could go wrong?
There's no way.
37 to five.
Certainly there's blood potential here,
but uh,
I liked the bills by the way.
My wife is mocking me right now,
talking sports on the radio,
talking sports ball,
talking sports,
swallow,
watching sports.
Hey,
it's the,
it's the life of a sports fan,
right?
Yeah.
Last point,
Sean.
Yes,
because I'm also on the bills.
Guess who the Patriots have on deck?
The packers come into town.
Oh look,
a head game.
APPS,
they look at spot.
I Dunno.
Packers aren't that good.
Kind of a stretch.
But pets are pretty disciplined,
but still 1414 point Monday night at home dog,
there's this,
this is their Superbowl.
They're gonna.
They're going to be fucking going crazy in buffalo.
So I think you got to take the big numbers there.
Okay.
No,
that's a great,
that's a great point.
Yeah.
Great Point.
I like that bag,
by the way.
I went to a buffalo bills game and I had a patriots hat on their plan,
the jets.
I was rooting for the bills and I made the mistake of going into the men's.
Oh God just started getting all this crap and they waited til I started to take
a leak and somebody pushed me.
That's dirty.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But they don't try to kill you.
They just,
they're just,
yeah,
they're more like a,
you know,
just like,
I don't know.
They just want you to bathe,
bathe in your own urine.
Classy fan base that she shot out of Sarah at buffalo
by the end of the year.
I want to label all sports fans so we're animals or the east coast.
They're killers on the west coast and that cheap shot artists in buffalo.
All right.
How many more buckets do we have left?
Watch out for bills Mafia.
We got to go through it and solve each market.
[inaudible] the Midwest is coming.
Oh yeah.
Look out.
I don't know what they try to bend your wife into the cheese or something.
Yeah,
we'll figure something out.
Some tainted beef.
All right,
Bill,
as always,
appreciate you calling in and as always,
the big things to my bookie daddy g promo code bill beds for 100% deposit bonus.
Uh,
use that Promo Code Bill Bets in game wagering,
props,
live betting.
They got it all over at my bookie,
daddy g and a make sure you check out bill burr and the all things comedy
festival heading heading to Phoenix this weekend,
October 25th to 28th I know he got a lot of a Phoenix listeners so if you
haven't gotten tickets already,
make sure you go check out the ATC crew over there.
All right bill,
I appreciate you calling in man.
Alright guys,
thanks for having me on.
Yeah,
yeah man.
Full of Shit.
Yeah,
it was fucking raining on this.
And one thing I've learned that when you go to a football game and you're
dealing with the elements,
this is the more of a Douche bag you look like the warmer you're going to be.
All right.
I saw the rain and I said fuck this.
And we went right to Dick's sporting goods and I'm like,
I'm buying that fucking,
I'm going to buy a rain coat with the matching raincoats slacks.
I don't give a fuck.
I bought a pair of wool socks and I was good to go.
So I'm with Versie and you know,
they only had like two raincoats left and they were the exact same color.
This fucking grapes,
slush,
puppy purple.
So we both have matching extra large fucking,
we got the jackets and the pants like we're working at a fucking airport and
what green we're bringing in the fucking soul plane,
right?
That was a purple airplane.
Right.
That's what we look like.
So we show up to the game,
right?
Neither one of us has comfortable because neither one of us is a jets or a bills
fan.
So we're in enemy territory and a,
it's fucking drizzling and out.
It's fucking cold.
So I proceed to put on this Barney the dinosaur outfit,
right?
And right off the bat,
Versie starts pumping outgoing,
man.
I'm just gonna.
I'm just gonna wear that.
I'm just going to wear the top.
I'm just going to wear the top trying to act like it's not raining out that bad.
The reality is,
is he didn't want to go through the hazing that he would have to if the two of
us walked in with our purple on Purple fucking raincoats times too.
We would've got a ton of shit and I was prepared to take it.
I had an,
I had a whole fucking silly walk I was going to be doing.
I don't give a fuck.
So he pumped out.
So,
uh,
we ended up walking in and put my head's cold,
right?
All I have is a baseball cap on.
So I'm like,
fuck,
I gotta buy a head.
Can I buy a bills?
Who gives a fuck?
They were in last place,
mail by a bill's hat and then I saw this,
this one with the Patriot logo on it.
I said,
fuck it.
I'll get that.
Once I put that one on,
I'm nice and warm.
We go to,
we'll call,
we pick up our tickets.
We go into that high school football stadium that they have out there that I
actually love.
It looks like an old school football stadium.
You know what I like about that football stadium that's about the size of a
football stadium that holds real fans,
you know what I mean?
All these,
these new ones that hold like 100,000 fucking pets,
all the bandwagon shit hits.
You know when you're all in for the real fucking fans show up are Oh and three,
right?
So we walk into the Goddamn stadium we love in life,
I'm already laughing at [inaudible] cause I know damn well what's going to
happen?
He's going to walk out there,
there's going to be some shitty little plastic seat that's going to be covered
in fucking water and the only way he's going to be able to absorb it is through
his God damn jeans and his fucking DVDs.
And then he's going to be sitting there with a wrinkled up nut sack that's going
to be getting hypothermia by second quarter.
Why do I know this?
Because I've been there.
So we get a couple of beers,
we get this fucking beef on a stick or whatever the fuck they call it.
We're good to go.
We go in there,
sit down,
he sits basically down in a fucking puddle.
He tried to stick a newspaper down,
which is a very absorbent and uh,
I don't know,
we sat there and I had hoped for about eight seconds in that game and the jets
came down and just fucking did they just kick the shit out of him.
Christ.
They kicked the shit out of 'em and uh,
it was just over him.
So we,
so immediately our solution is just to start drinking the way we drank at the
masters.
We're like,
fuck it,
let's,
let's get going here.
Right?
So we'll make a trip after trip and all of a sudden I gotta take a Piss.
So I go and I'm standing in line and all of a sudden this,
this fucking six foot five goofy looking jackass,
one of those guys who's like six foot five,
but you still think he can take him cause he's just covered in baby fat.
You know,
he's got a couple of whiskers on his chin and his cheeks,
her rosier than Saint Nick.
Right?
And he's got this Jersey on and this big stupid,
I'm a buffalo bills fan with the horns on it and stuff.
You know,
he's the Wacky Guy,
so I'm not even thinking shit.
Right.
This is bill's jets.
I don't have a dog in this fight.
I'm not talking any shit.
I'm fine.
I forgot I was wearing my patriots hat and all of a sudden this big goofy
jackass starts going,
wait,
what?
Yeah,
we'll,
you're a patriots fan.
He liked the rats.
We got ran over here.
The rats.
He likes to fucking reds this shit.
Right?
And I'm like,
yeah,
no,
whatever.
He starts giving me Shit,
I start giving them shit back then the weirdest fucking thing happened.
I,
by the time I get in to the actual men's room,
I've talked,
I've given these people so much fucking shit that actually there's bills and
jets fans at a bills and jets game.
They're playing each other.
They stopped giving each other shit and they teamed up together and started
giving me shit.
Right.
And then I just said,
I don't know what I was thinking.
I felt like I was on stage cause it was like a crowd.
I wasn't thinking like,
Hey,
you know what,
Bill,
you really haven't had a fight outside of your family since maybe playing
fucking street hockey in the sixth grade.
I didn't give a fuck.
I'm in a goddamn bathroom waiting to take a piss in a goddamn trough,
by the way.
And uh,
and then they just started giving me a fucking,
this one dude such going,
Tom Brady Sucks Dick.
He Sucks Dick.
And he's like,
miming it like ridiculously well.
So I'm like,
Hey,
you know,
do you do that real wealth?
Because I learned it by watching Tom Brady.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
did you rent that porno?
You fucking fag gets a little uglier,
gets a little uglier than this other dude.
What the fuck did you do?
I came up with the hell he was saying to me,
and I just said,
look,
I'm sorry you guys have never won a Superbowl.
You know,
then the jets fan pipes in.
I go,
do you realize the last time you guys won a Superbowl,
Charlie Chaplin was still alive?
Do you understand that?
Do you know what cars look like the last time you won?
You fucking morons.
And then,
uh,
then this other guy got one,
two,
we've won three super bowls,
I'm sorry.
Right?
And then the guy goes,
well,
you didn't play in the games.
I go,
neither did yo.
Then he's just standing there with this dumb look on his face.
Like,
oh,
that's right.
Keep staring forward.
You got nothing for getting that.
I don't know how to fight.
So all of a sudden it's my turn to Piss.
I take my dick out,
I'm ready to Piss.
And one of these fucking pussies pushed me in the back hoping that I was pissing
at the time.
Fortunately I wasn't.
So I turn around,
I put my dick away cause I'm a gentleman and I said,
well gee,
I goes and how you guys do it out here.
Really?
I go,
which one do you guys push me?
Like I'm gonna Fuck,
I'm fucking Jackie Chan.
And for some reason none of them said anything.
I don't know if it was my purple on purple rain coat or the look of fire in my
eye,
but I'm a fucking 42 year old,
balding redhead talking shit in there.
And none of them said anything.
So now it's kind of funny to me.
I felt like I was in like the world series of poker and I went all in and I,
and I didn't have a hand whatsoever.
So I don't know who the fuck pushed me.
But that's what I mean.
Come on.
Bitchy is move with a fucking week.
How do you do that?
How do you,
how do you push another man when he's got his Goddamn Dick out trying to piss
into a fucking trough?
I mean,
how do you get lower than that?
Do you guys have any ideas?
How do you get lower than that?
So then after none of them said anything,
I go back and I started taking a piss.
And then that other dude who was miming somebody's sucking
a dick unbelievably well right next to me.
One of those stupid hats that has the toggles on the side and he's still trying
to give me shit and I'm gonna go fuck yourself.
And then he just starts screaming over and over again.
Are you looking at my deck?
Are you looking at my deck like maniacally,
like five times.
I just sort of stared at him.
Michael,
why do you keep going with this gay angle?
Like why is there always a,
I don't know.
I think he was one of those guys.
He was kind of in the closet and then uh,
so he just goes to football games and he gets really drunk trying to just kill
the families.
I think he liked me is what I'm saying.
So if he's listening to this,
I'm sorry.
Uh,
I'm spoken for you fucking pants.
You fucking believe that.
First of all,
what's wrong with me?
I really replay it,
all of that in my head.
Cause once I got out of there I was like,
I really started thinking like,
what?
What did you think you were going to do in there?
They're not Clint Eastwood yet saying things.
Clint Eastwood would say,
what?
What the fuck is wrong with you dude?
Like,
I don't know if I've said this before in a podcast,
a public bathroom is the worst fucking place to ever get into a fight.
There is nothing soft.
There's everything is porcelain pipes,
that concrete floor and then it has a mist of piss and shit.
It's just the fuck it,
it's the worst.
It's the worst place ever,
you know,
not to mention it usually starts evidently when one person as begun,
the pissing processing.
So,
uh,
you know,
older little bit wiser.
So then I'm standing in line to go get some more alcohol cause God knows that's
what you need after an incident like that.
And I was just kinda just sitting there thinking like,
all right,
now how should I have played that?
It w it should have ended when the dude with the water buffalo hat started
giving me shit.
What I should've done was roll with it.
I should you like to patriots.
I should've been like,
hey,
you know you guys scored 30 on his last week,
man.
You guys look great man.
I,
I bet the jets,
I mean I bet against the jets.
I hope you guys should have just ended it with that and did it.
I sh I should have,
I should have extended an olive branch.
That's what I should've done in the future.
That's what the fuck I'm going to do because,
uh,
that was a,
that was a potentially ugly situation.
But fortunately,
um,
I think the people who were doing it,
you know,
had jobs and no one wanted to get sued and no one was willing to take it to that
level.
Uh,
and when I say fortunately,
I mean for me in my face,
oh,
do you know how bad that have been to get stomped in that fucking purple on
purple rain coat laying there with my dirty fucking patriots hat
and my team wasn't even playing.
I would have lost the lawsuit.
They would've been like,
let me get this straight.
You're a patriots fan.
You're a patriots hat to a bill's jets game,
and you somehow managed to get the shit kicked out of you.
What the fuck did you say?
You know,
that's one of the great things about being a guy is you actually have to take
responsibility for your,
for your action.
See you.
What would it be like?
There's no excuse.
There's no reason.
I don't care what happened.
You don't hit a girl,
which is true.
You don't have a fucking girl,
but there's no learning in that.
There's no lesson.
You know,
even my best friends would have been like,
yeah,
those guys
fucking assholes in the,
but you know,
they would have been an awkward pause.
And I'd be like,
dude,
what the fuck?
He talking shit for by yourself at a game when your team isn't even fucking
play.
What's wrong with you?
You're 42 years old.
Get his shit together.
And they would have been right.
Me and my shot
[inaudible] man in a pot full of shit.
[inaudible]
yeah.
And I'm gonna kill that woman.
[inaudible]
mom going through again that d dog
have so many other Friday.
They won the watershed.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
October 25th,
2010 hi,
you doing Joe?
What's going on?
Um,
I just got back from a,
a awesome tour.
Okay.
A quick three,
four day tour,
three nights of a wonderful theaters.
I feel like a big shot.
I worked the Wilbur Theater in Boston on Wednesday doing a fund raiser.
Yeah.
And then I did the pantageous theater in Minneapolis,
Minnesota.
One of the most underrated cities I've ever been to.
Minneapolis was the shit.
And I was bummed that I was only there for a day.
And then I went to Chicago and played the Vic theater,
which evidently Dennis Miller did one of his recent specials that,
you know,
I love the toad babe.
I love the toad fucking quick way with the fucking coca choke bank,
you know,
one of my favorites of all time.
Um,
so I got to stand on the same stage.
I guess they did some HBO half hours there.
I heard a talk that Bill Hicks had possibly perform there.
So it was a a,
it was an amazing night tour,
I should say.
Not An,
of course.
I had the wonderful,
uh,
teen idol sensation from the opiate Anthony Program,
Joe de Rosa opening for me the entire time.
And uh,
believe it or not,
I hung out with Joe to Rosa and did not have a drop of alcohol.
All right.
Now I know a lot of you are familiar with Joe to Rosa.
For those of you who aren't Joe is,
um,
how do I put this?
Joe is a drunk,
um,
in every sense of the word.
He literally,
you know,
the amount of times he can't find his keys and passes out in some sort of fetal
position on the stoop of his building is just,
it's,
it's really just something I'm,
I'm starting to get nervous about,
you know,
and I'm sort of codependent.
So when he starts coming around with his fucking half Egyptian WC fields,
red fucking knows the booze usually starts flowing.
But I don't know what happened.
I got back into the zone.
I got back into the fucking zone of not Busan.
I had a,
I had to Heinekens and I know a lot of your beer drinkers will be like,
well,
that,
that'll do it.
Do it.
It's too fucking better,
too hoppy.
Um,
I had a couple of Heinekens A,
I dunno,
we could go last Saturday night.
I was like,
you know what?
I think I'm fucking sick of this.
Yeah.
You know,
I think my head is about big enough.
I think it's,
it's,
I think it's pretty much,
can't even say waterlogged alcohol log,
you know?
That's where I really figured out why I don't like boozing is because drinking a
ton of beer is the male equivalent to when females bitch about retaining water
and they just feel fucking bloated.
May Be honest with yourself.
It might not happen the day of the tailgate,
but a couple of days after the wings and those fucking Goddamn 16 ounce beers
you were drinking,
you just wake up in the morning,
stumble into,
go brush your teeth and you're like,
whoa.
You just look at that fucking
am I head is the size of like a fucking industrial like cookie jar.
If they made one and I was sick of it,
I haven't posted in like seven days and I'm noticing,
uh,
or eight days or nine days,
I'm up to nine days here.
It's kind of,
it's starting to fucking shrink a little bit and I already had a fucking big
goddamn head to,
the last thing I needed to do was to be adding Chins to it.
You know,
it's not even when you see a guy who was always sort of jolly will say,
rather than I'm in a good mood this week,
I'm not going to say he's a fat fuck,
we'll just say a jolly guy.
Right.
Um,
you know,
his whole life,
Husky,
you know,
healthy on that dude.
You know,
you say I'm a five,
10 years later in his head's even bigger year,
a year expected.
But for me it's,
it's when you see the,
the,
the bean pole guys,
there's a couple of celebrities out there.
I don't name names on the podcast,
but there's just one in particular who back in the day it looked like you could
pick them up with two fingers and just walk them over to a table,
you know,
and uh,
saw him the other day and it's just like,
dude,
you know what it really is?
I think it's because it has to do with not being married,
believe it or not add it's bullshit.
Because what if you're married to the wrong person,
then you can be depressed.
You'd be eating.
I don't fucking know.
All I know is I,
I've,
I've figured something out here is far as where if I'm going to continue
boozing,
I'm going to be doing it.
And it's definitely in the hotel lobby of wherever I'm staying at because that
is a much more mature place for some of my,
somewhat of my age to be at.
If you like make in your travel a lot and yet you keep trying to visit your old
haunts places,
you know,
that you'd go to when you were in your 20s,
possibly your early thirties.
They,
you just can't do it after a while.
You know,
you walk in and you know,
you just look like the date rape drug guy.
I mean,
why else?
If you're not the club owner,
how else do you honestly think something's going to happen in there?
Right?
So what you want to do is you go to the hotel lobby and there what you will find
is a unhappily married people
and some call girls.
You know,
I sat there stone sober with Joe de Rosa.
We actually hung out one night and did not drink the night of the,
uh,
the show at the Vic theater,
which was fucking unbelievable by the way.
Um,
place was sold out and I cannot thank the people,
the good people of Chicago enough.
That's a great fucking city.
That is a great guy,
damn city.
You know the fucker's know how to eat,
they know how to drink,
they know how to grow a mustache and they won a Stanley Cup.
They were in a great fucking mood and I went up there and had an awesome set.
But anyways,
so we hung out at this,
this um,
hung out there.
Yeah,
the hotel lounge.
And we were just laughing about how pathetic our friendship is when you remove
alcohol.
We sat there,
oh,
this is a fucking dude I've known for seven years in the fact that we weren't
drinking and breaking balls at that hour of the night.
It was like an awkward first date
just sitting there other than just making fun of how we had absolutely nothing
to talk about.
And that's when we just started looking around,
looking at the people look like that movie up in the air someplace.
I Clooney's character would hang out.
And we're just sitting there laughing,
trying to get the jobs that people are doing,
you know?
And then all of a sudden these two fucking knockouts out of nowhere come walking
by and you know,
so I do what you always do.
You fucking look at them.
You don't look at them right in the eye.
And this is what gave him away.
They didn't look away.
And I was like,
oh,
they're professionals.
Wow.
This is a whole,
there's a whole new environment.
I gotta admit I liked it.
The music wasn't loud.
It was totally geared for a 42 year old loser like myself.
And I really enjoyed myself.
I didn't had a water and I ate a case of dia and I,
uh,
I don't know.
I had a great fucking time,
so I'm going to see how long I can go.
I'm really going to,
I'm going to try to go until the Rosebowl cause you know,
you know my rule,
I got to start the year off right by a,
just making a complete ass of myself at the granddaddy of them all.
So if I make it that far,
that'll be 76 days sober.
Saw break my old record by one day and I won't,
I won't put it so fucking far out of reach that when I started drinking again,
I won't feel like I can't get back to,
you know,
maybe 77 days.
All right.
Was that boring?
Good.
This is the new sober meek.
I get no stories from the road.
Oh,
let's talk about our Minneapolis.
Why Minneapolis was the shit.
I actually,
uh,
I got an a day early and I'm like,
God damn it.
I don't have my phone on me.
I did a great radio show.
I forget the name of it of course,
because I was half asleep.
Phenomenal fucking interview.
And I'm actually going to start listening to the show online.
We'll have this information on the [inaudible] podcast.
I just kind of woke up and did this podcast so I don't have my fucking phone
with me.
Um,
and then I actually,
I took a tour.
This is how much of a sports Goddamn nerd I am.
I took a tour of the twins,
knew a baseball stadium.
The target,
uh,
target field to target fucking owns Minneapolis.
All right.
The way Jp Morgan owned Manhattan back in the day when he used to walk around
with his top hat in his shoes with those fucking white things around the ankles
to let people know that you're fucking rich.
Target owns that Goddamn city.
But uh,
if you're in Minneapolis,
you need to kill a couple of fucking hours before a flight.
I suggest taking a tour of a target field before they close it down for the
awareness.
It was awesome.
It was a fucking great ball park.
I definitely want to come back to Minneapolis and uh,
it's another one.
They had good food.
They had a,
all of this whole strip of restaurants and then where I played the pantageous,
they had a whole strip of theaters.
They had all little scene going on.
Great bars.
You know,
that I stood in not drinking,
having drunk people from the show coming up to me,
you know,
talking to me,
realizing that this is what you look like,
Bill,
here's a little life lesson,
but I do,
I do.
I have to criticize Minneapolis about one thing.
Uh,
I walked by one of their,
uh,
their bus stops and I guess it was a major bus stop because it was 40 people
there,
40 of the brokest look and fucking people I've ever seen in my life.
Okay.
White,
black,
Asian.
I don't give a fuck what race I,
there was no connection to make.
Like how this level of brokeness happened.
I walked by,
I was actually nervous.
I was like,
someone's gonna slug me in the head and try to take my fucking wallet because if
I looked at the way these fucking people looked,
I would do the exact same thing.
I saw a meth couple.
I don't know what they were.
He's dirty,
uh,
looking people.
The girl looked like a,
I don't know.
She was high on something and they had a baby.
She had a baby man.
Shit fucking baby sitting there right by the,
uh,
the bus stop.
It was just a,
yeah,
but you ever just want to rescue a baby?
Not like abduct him.
You know,
you just rescue them like you would a goddamn dog and one of those Sarah
mclachlan commercials,
why don't they have a commercial?
Why can't you do that?
If you see a meth couple drugged out couple,
you know,
and they're sitting down on the fucking sidewalk,
like to lay on a bed with fresh linens,
with a fucking baby,
you know,
I wonder what they,
they,
they would charge you with abduction.
But I,
how much,
how much of any lawyers listen to this shit?
How much time would you get if you just saw like,
look,
the fucking baby was being neglected.
So I took it.
He could get away with that shit.
You really couldn't.
They'd be like,
well,
why didn't you call the proper services?
Uh,
cause I don't know what that would involve looking shit up and trying to find a
number.
I went with the,
uh,
the immediacy of just fucking taken it.
All right.
I believe I've meandered enough.
Here's,
here's a couple of comments from past white,
uh,
white pass,
podcast.
Uh,
this one's called the white man,
what I call it.
Uh,
oh,
someone said,
uh,
hey,
bill and behind in podcast.
So you may have already gotten emails about this,
but Christopher Columbus was actually a redhead.
I was making fun of Christopher Columbus a few weeks ago on Columbus Day.
And uh,
this guy is saying Christopher.
Oh,
I remember what I said.
I was saying how Christopher Columbus,
actually,
he had blonde hair in my history books.
So this guy is saying he was actually a redhead.
I think throughout history,
anyone who decided to walk,
sale,
fly,
swim toward toward inevitable doom at the end of the world was inevitably a
psychotic ginger.
That would have been good.
Can I give you some tips on joke writing?
Don't use the same word in the setup and in the punch.
You said inevitable twice.
And of course I'm reading it,
so that really kills it.
Now this goes back to my theory of,
uh,
when they,
they talk about new information throughout history.
When exactly did they suddenly discover that he was a redhead?
Did you find some 600 year old whore who actually used to bang them
and she was just,
yeah,
he actually,
he had red hair.
Carpets matched the drakes.
Um,
that's like the,
that's like the fucking,
uh,
the,
these,
these black dudes that was standing on the corner of Minneapolis,
uh,
you know,
those guys who scream about religion,
do they ever have like the levels of their pa a juxtapose correctly?
They are always talking way too loud.
Do you have a mother fucker?
And you know what's funny is half to white people who walk by,
they probably think that they're getting,
making that face,
like disapproving of the message rather than the level of,
it's just,
dude.
Yeah.
Get a new fucking PA,
get a fucking Goddamn,
uh,
whatever the fuck you call the person who knows how to run the board.
Make it a clean sound.
Okay.
Instead of being like,
[inaudible],
what's your black,
oh,
the paradox.
Excuse me,
sir.
Not trying to interrupt your hate.
Um,
I just,
it's really difficult to understand what it is I'm supposed to be offended by
when I can't understand what it is you're saying.
Okay.
Um,
Joe Rosa actually said to the Guy Jesus was white and one of his,
his,
uh,
terminator x guys actually laughed and then another guy stared at him and then
he went right back to the,
uh,
fuck white people face.
Once again.
Another classic example why I stay away from organized religion because it leads
you to that.
You know,
Jesus loves everybody,
but he's our color and he loves us best,
but he loves everyone.
Um,
anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
I'm sure that bothered a lot of your ears.
I apologize for that,
but that's literally what the fuck it sounded like.
MMM.
Yeah.
I would like to do that on a street corner.
I have a really bad pa like that and just be saying a bunch of fucking reverse
racist shit about white people.
I wonder if anybody would get it,
the amount of people who wouldn't,
that was what would make it really hilarious.
Yeah.
But he's white.
I don't understand.
Um,
all right,
here's a quick question that I got this week,
uh,
on Peyton manning a bill.
I am a college student in New York City and I love the podcast and your comedy.
I am a die hard giants fan and the kid down the hall is from Indiana.
And as a colts fan,
for some reason he feels the giants were lucky to beat the 18 and oh patriots
and that they flat out suck.
Um,
but Peyton was not lucky to win against the rex Grossman led.
Here's your fucking Superbowl coats.
Chicago bears.
I need you to go on another rant to explain these two super bowls and which one
was more legitimate?
Um,
all right.
First of all,
you're,
you're playing into his hand.
All right?
He's just deliberately saying,
shit that's gonna Piss you off and,
and you're,
you're taking the bait.
All right.
The giants weren't lucky.
The giants are actually,
the 2007 giants are arguably the most underrated Superbowl team of all fucking
time because everyone was so fixated that the patriots lost.
That was the story rather than
the giants had one of the most undeniable championships of all time.
They were on the road the whole time.
They went down to Tampa Bay,
they beat Tampa in Tampa.
Then they went to Dallas,
beat the cowboys in Dallas,
then they went to green bay and beat Green Bay in fucking Greenbay.
And then they went to to,
uh,
the Superbowl and for some reason was 17 point underdogs to a team that they
scored like 35 points on a month earlier,
still kicking myself in the ass that I didn't take that bet.
Um,
and fucking just,
you know,
blasted the Patriots right in the mouth,
kick their fucking ass.
They're really kicked our ass because of the score.
But as far as like when it really came down to like a,
just the offense,
the defensive line just crushed our offensive line.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't think they're underrated at all.
I actually don't feel that the 2007 giants get the respect that they deserve and
it's a fucking shame that the patriots hadn't lost just one game.
So then maybe they could have focused on that.
I mean,
my theory is if the Patriots actually just lost the game during the regular
season,
maybe they could have just,
they could,
uh,
actually had a weekend to themselves and not at a bunch of cameras up their
asses.
Um,
anyways,
I,
so I,
I totally disagree with that,
but I think this guy's just trying to piss you off.
And as far as the,
uh,
the colts play in the bears,
I mean,
it's not their fault that the bears,
that the,
all these other NFC teams couldn't beat fucking rex Grossman,
if I remember correctly.
Rex Grossman,
anything beyond 12 yards was a hail Mary.
Am I crazy thinking that shit?
Am I crazy?
This whole call?
What
these motherfuckers,
lot of Patrick Shit can have black quarterback.
What the fuck was that show called?
What ma'am?
Um,
anyways,
yeah,
so all he's trying to do is just,
uh,
he's just trying to piss you off and you're allowing that to happen.
And,
uh,
you know,
I don't,
I'm amazed that you are allowing that to happen because,
uh,
you know,
say what you want about rex Grossman,
he didn't throw a pick six to lose the fucking game.
He just kind of threw a bunch of shitty passes for four quarters.
All right.
Um,
speaking of which,
um,
I want to talk to San Diego charger this week and,
uh,
I want to know what the fuck you guys did to the football gods.
Okay.
Now this,
this is a group of people that,
uh,
evidently we're rivals with something that I wasn't aware of,
um,
because we usually beat them,
you know,
which always amazed me.
Y Yankee fans,
you know,
back in the day,
hated red sox fans.
It's just like,
why would you even bother do,
why did you even notice the music there between us and the fucking,
you know,
the Goddamn twins at this point,
we always lose to you,
you know,
back in the day.
Um,
but anyways,
like the amount of fucking times that the chargers have beaten the fucking
patriots and still lost the game is just,
it's just,
it's fucking beyond me.
Do you remember that one year in the uh,
I believe it was the playoffs.
Playoffs.
Um,
they like stopped us.
We were down,
I don't know how many points we were down,
but we were down,
it was the end of the game and they stopped us on fourth and short fucking games
over.
All they gotta do is take a knee and run out the clock,
but some fucking idiot on their defense gets like a personal foul on the play.
Completely unnecessary,
which gives the Patriots have first down and allows them to continue their drive
to then go ahead and,
and steal the fucking game.
Now yesterday wasn't the same scenario.
That was a case of the Patriots blow in the fucking game.
But it's like you're right there to tie it and you know,
if you tied it,
you're going to beat us.
You got to 45 yarder,
which is totally makeable by this guy.
And then someone on your offensive line has a fucking false start.
Five yard penalty.
Now it's a fucking 50.
Yarder I gotta be honest with you.
I thought,
I thought that that guy was going to miss the 45 yarder.
Uh,
he just didn't have that.
I'm going to nail this look on his face,
but then I thought once that guy got the five yard penalty and became a 50 yard
kick,
the fact that if he missed it,
it was people were going to be blaming the fucking cunt on the offensive line.
I figured maybe that took the pressure off it and he was going to hit it and lo
and behold,
the guy kicks it plenty of fucking leg.
And you know,
and just typical of the torture of that,
these I feel San Diego charger fans do not deserve at this point.
They have paid their fucking dues.
He didn't even have the decency to just kick it fucking wide.
Right.
And you knew the second was off his foot.
You could be like,
oh,
what the fuck?
Right.
It's the whole way you will,
you,
you couldn't tell either way.
Is it gonna is it gonna be good?
Is,
is he going to miss it?
It actually hit the upright and does it bounce in somehow miraculously and they
tied up now it just fucking falls to the ground kick is no good.
And um,
San Diego fans,
I want to know what do you think you did?
Cause I remember back in the day when the red sox would blow it and they had the
curse of the Babe,
you know,
at least we had something to,
to,
to try to blame it on.
What did you guys do out there?
Was it because,
uh,
was,
was there a group of Indians,
they're having a good time and then fucking Mr San Diego came in and fucking
raped and killed all of them.
The named that area after himself.
Is that what happened?
What happened out there?
Oh,
by the way,
this in,
in this week's,
this week's,
um,
or this month,
I don't even know if rollingstones monthly or weekly,
um,
edition.
They have that dead dude from entourage who plays the manager on our side was in
sports illustrated and they asked him how he felt when the red sox came back in
2004 and beat the Yankees and he's a big time Yankee Fan.
And he goes,
I was happy.
I was happy that they finally won it because I was so sick of them.
Listen to them complain.
How fucking hilarious is that really where you're really happy.
Oh,
I was glad you guys won.
Really?
We use sick or rubbing our noses.
You fucking lying piece of shit.
You were sitting there chatting in 1918 with all of them.
Jesus Christ.
That's like fucking Regis Filburn.
After we,
after we won it,
he was like,
yeah,
you want it.
You want it all right.
Whatever.
Enough already,
you know,
move on fucking faggot Yankee fans,
there's such pussies.
All they can do is talk shit for fucking all this time.
And then the second it comes around for them to talk and Shit,
they got to act like,
oh yeah,
yeah,
I'm happy for you guys.
Yeah,
I'm happy.
Stand there and take it.
You fucking midget.
Whatever the fuck you goddamn name is.
Manage your own entourage.
You weren't happy.
You were fucking pissed.
You had your head between your little fucking midget knobby knees.
Oh,
Jeff,
to the happy you guys want when the Yankees win.
I'm never happy I have the balls to fucking admit that.
All right there.
Fucking little man with a better career than me.
Her right then let's plow ahead.
Um,
it's amazing that we still won and his comments still pissed me off.
I wanted misery.
I wanted misery out of those guys.
I was speaking of,
which I don't even know what's going on in baseball.
I know the Rangers won.
Congratulations.
All right.
Which once again makes me wonder what the fuck the people of San Diego did.
Cause here it is.
The people of Dallas are just,
you know,
now I'm ready to blow my fucking head off that
Goddamn Tony Romo can't fucking complete if the fucking play college,
they go nuts down there.
All right,
here it is.
Baseball,
sports.
They don't even give a shit about,
actually wait a minute.
The longhorns are always in fucking,
uh,
the college world series aren't they?
But that's way down there and fucking Austin.
But whatever.
It's like the cowboys has shit in the Goddamn bed and uh,
then all of a sudden the rage is,
come on,
give them something to fucking Shira Bob.
So I don't know actually like the Phillies and I like the giants at,
uh,
I guess just because the giants haven't won it so long,
I'd like,
I'd love to see the rangers first of giants and I think I'll actually watch the
goddamn world series.
I actually,
when the ranger started kicking the shit out of the Yankees,
I started,
you know,
peaking into bars and watching it because I was amazed at a $55 million team
could have such a great lineup.
And what sucks about baseball is half those guys will end up on the red sox or
the fucking Yankees,
uh,
which really has to stop or am I completely full or,
or am I completely full of Shit?
Because despite the fact that the fucking red sox spent all that goddamned
money,
did they make the playoffs?
No,
they did not.
And could the Yankees beat of $55 million team?
No,
they couldn't.
And plus the muscles finally starting to read all this shit about these other
fucking cheap bastard known as like the Goddamn guys with the pirates who just
make a profit every year and don't even try to make,
put a winner on the field.
I think the whole God damn sport needs to be rehauled.
That's what the fuck I say.
Rehauled or overhauled.
Do you know I was watching the,
uh,
this is just a completely random podcasts.
I was watching the Jersey shore last night though the final episode and uh,
I just love how they fuck up sayings.
W Snookie said she was upset about something and said that her blood pressure
was off the roof.
My blood pressure's off the roof,
not going through the roof,
not off the charts.
It was off the roof.
God bless that big titted fucking you don't,
she's going to be a great mother.
I don't know what it is about her.
She's going to be a great mother,
but she,
she,
I don't know if she's ever going to get married because so much footage exists
of a,
I don't even know if a lot of footage exists cause I didn't really watch it this
year,
this season.
But you know,
once you do like a fucking whatever that,
that backwards cartwheel that you did and they have to pixelate your pussy lips
hanging out of your fucking Thong.
I mean that,
that you're really limiting the amount of people that are going to want to go
out on a date with you.
Something that she continues to,
to,
uh,
to bit your Bob,
you know,
her tits take up your entire torso.
If you notice that they start right under her,
Adam,
the Adam's apple,
and they go right to the top of where her pubes grow,
which is another thing that's working against her.
But you gotta admit she's got a lot of talent.
Her ability to do that back flip in,
not like
what are those fucking things?
One of those weebles wobble,
but they don't fall down at some point like that.
That should be like impossible for her to do.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
What am I talking about this week?
Um,
yeah,
so the fucking patriots won.
I think we're one of the weakest five and one goddamn teams out there,
but we're five and one tied with the Goddamn jets.
What do you think about debt?
You Green,
bald fucking cunts.
Um,
anyways,
oh,
this week,
by the way,
let me hype some,
uh,
some of the shit I got going on.
I have a,
I'm going to be going to,
um,
Saint Louis this weekend.
I'm doing a benefit on Friday night and on Saturday night I'm doing two shows
one night only at the funny bone of Saint Louis.
I haven't been here.
I haven't been there in a,
put it this way.
The last time I went there was the first year of new Busch Stadium,
I believe.
Yeah.
Whenever the fuck that was.
It's,
it's been a good five,
six years.
I want to say,
I don't know.
I spent a long goddamn time so please come out to that show.
I will have my new DVDs for sale and I can't stress how much you're going to be
happy if you buy that goddamn thing because comedy central,
because they actually make their money through advertising,
had not their fault,
had to cut out 16 minutes of that special plus an extra five minutes because his
special is an hour and five minutes long.
So with the 16 minutes of commercials plus the extra five minutes,
21 minutes of that special you have not seen.
And the overwhelming response I've gotten from people was like,
Holy Shit,
I can't believe they cut out all this stuff.
I mean I get why they did it.
I wish they showed it over 90 minutes and you could see the whole special,
but um,
you won't be disappointed.
And I have extras actually filmed one of my Monday morning podcasts.
If you're ever curious to see what I look like sitting in sweatpants,
talking into a mic by myself.
We've got that footage.
And some footage of me getting heckled and giving people shit back.
All right,
so that is it.
And I'm hanging around to go to the fucking rams game,
the rams game,
which will be my 101st professional franchise that I have been to,
uh,
trying to go to all 123.
And this,
this week I actually,
when I was on the plane,
this is how I'm,
I try to,
uh,
kill time when I'm on the plane is uh,
I don't know.
I,
I try to,
if I write down the,
the teams that I haven't seen,
this is really psycho and I'll do it with my right hand cause I'm a lefty,
right?
Trying to develop that skill because I feel like my brain's turning to mush
talking on cell phones.
And uh,
this week I actually,
and I'm,
well I'm going to complete this list and put it up on the [inaudible] podcast.
I actually,
um,
started to compile a list of the names of all the stadiums that I've been to.
And a,
I got to admit,
it's pretty,
it's getting pretty fucking impressive at this point.
Some of the classics that I've been to,
some of the ones that aren't there anymore,
like Old Tiger Stadium,
old Yankee stadium.
Uh,
and even like the random ones,
like county stadium.
I remember that one with like the brewers back in the day when they used to hit
home runs,
every time they hit a home run,
they had this big fucking tinted whore would slide down into a slide into what
was supposed to be an old school keg of beer,
you know,
I dunno.
So good God damn time.
Um,
so I'll have that list up there.
Seriously,
if you ever sports nerd,
if you don't,
if you're not into it,
who gives a fuck?
Um,
all right.
This podcast is grinding to a God damn halt.
All right,
let's get to some advice here.
Bill.
I met a girl on a online dating site and uh,
we hit it off and we both thought each other
as friends.
Now,
you know,
usually I,
I blame myself when I,
when I don't read these well,
but this,
this one is really not written well.
He misses words and he misspells the,
the rest of them.
So just bear with me.
All right.
So basically this guy,
I met this girl on an online dating site.
They hit it off and they both think of each other as friends while over the last
nine months,
we became good friends.
Even after I moved eight hours,
eight hours days,
you mean eight hours away.
Oh,
you got a job and you're working eight hour days.
I have no idea.
During the last three months,
um,
she lost or last 25 pounds,
lost 25 pounds and told me,
uh,
she was bipolar and old geesh.
Jesus Christ dude.
Okay.
And over this time she keeps calling
and started treating me like a boyfriend.
So obviously you're fucking are.
Okay.
So you're,
you're hanging out with this girl for eight months and you're banging her.
So yeah,
she's going to start treating you like a boyfriend.
A few weeks ago I was invited to her family's beach house for the weekend and
met her whole family.
While I was there,
her mother introduced me to their family and friends as the guide.
Jane has been dating for the last four months.
I blew it off.
Why would you blow that off?
I guess her mother could,
you know,
was just trying to save her a daughter's reputation.
Hey,
this is my daughter's a friend friend with benefits.
Yeah,
he's banging her,
but there's really nothing going on here.
Oh,
these kids today.
Um,
I blew it off and enjoyed the weekend,
uh,
three weeks ago.
It's,
um,
it's gotten really bad and I'm trying to distance myself.
And the other night I asked her if she thought of me more than a friend and she
said no.
And it gave me the friend speech and then as why I felt that she might have felt
this way and gave me some examples about calling me.
Oh.
And then she gave you some examples about calling her all the time and telling a
few other personal things.
Well,
two days later she called me and said that she can't be friends with me anymore
because every time we talk or hang out together,
uh,
it gets tougher because she's always going to think that she,
she's giving you,
she's giving.
Oh,
giving you the,
I like you more than a friend vibe.
Um,
I feel really bad and that what I said might have caused her to have a major
episode.
What,
like bipolar episode.
And we talked so much,
I didn't really realize how much of a part of a life my life she was and I did
have feelings for what do I do?
All right.
First things first.
This is why that friends with benefit thing doesn't work for so many people.
Because friends with benefits,
if you're hanging out with someone of the opposite sex,
they're going to start getting feelings for you.
So the only way to do the friends with benefit things is you can only,
you can only bang them and,
but what you have to do is there has to be a significant period of time
between you.
You banging that you bang them and then you fucking leave.
But inevitably something like this,
someone's going to get,
get some feelings and it's,
it's an impossible thing to do.
It's like what you're doing is you had a one night stand and you,
you are either through being selfish or just lacking the confidence of you being
able to pull off,
getting laid again.
You try to keep them,
I can only speak of this from the male side.
You try to keep this person in your fucking,
uh,
in a holding pattern around your life and uh,
yeah,
of course she's going to end up catching some feelings.
You're going to end up hurting the person.
You can't.
You mean if you're just friends,
what the fuck he going over meeting her parents for?
You know,
like that level is shit.
No matter how much you've said from the get go,
that look,
I don't want anything more than this.
We just,
I just view you as a friend.
If you go over and you meet her parents like that says something.
All right.
So my advice is,
is if you like this girl,
make her your girlfriend.
If you don't like her,
stop fucking her because you're hurting her.
You know,
that's all you're doing is because she's going to forget about the fact that she
has these,
these,
this by bipolar disorder or whatever.
Now obviously,
I don't know how that fucking plays into it.
Um,
but yeah,
dude,
you gotta you gotta man up and have the balls to either make this girl your
girlfriend or man up and just be alone,
which is how most people,
I think fuck up their dating careers and getting married and all that is just,
they have a fear of being alone and they don't want to,
uh,
just ride out that fucking six weeks.
You know,
going through the first few days of spooning with your pillow and crying and
feeling sorry for yourself and just learning how to pick yourself up off the
mat.
Join a gym,
right?
Get yourself in shape,
hang out with the fellas,
watch some games.
You know,
it's only
being single,
really just,
it sucks on days off and it's sucks at night.
But other than that,
it's a,
it's pretty fucking awesome,
you know,
to just kind of be able to walk into places,
scope out every chick there and be like,
I want to try to fuck her.
Or maybe that's the girl I want to marry like that.
That's a great situation to be in,
in.
It's worth the loneliness.
Come on,
be honest with me.
How many people out there are fucking with somebody right now you don't want to
be with.
And you go into these family fucking advance.
You know when you just feel the new skit and tighter and tighter around your
neck.
I'm telling you,
just get out of it.
And when you get out of it,
go through the pain of being single on,
of,
of going through the breakup.
Don't just go out and run back to the person.
Don't fucking go out and just start dating somebody else and just use that
person to fill up your fucking loneliness.
Like really just be alone.
And when you,
you know,
I'm telling you I have to fucking couple of weeks,
you're going to get through it and then
you'll be comfortable being by yourself and then you can have a quiet fucking
mind that isn't thinking panic thoughts and he can just kind of make a list of
what the fuck you looking for,
you know,
and ask for if you don't know what to,
where to find it as for some goddamn advice.
But the last thing you do is,
uh,
is,
is getting involved in a situation like this where it's like,
dude,
if you really gave a fuck about this girl,
wouldn't when you made her your girl or maybe you're afraid to make her,
her,
your girlfriend.
I don't know what.
But,
uh,
that's my advice.
I would do one or the other,
actually commit to this girl and try to make it happen.
Um,
or just get away from her.
All right?
But I gotta admit you're really taken on a hell of a fucking thing here where
you've got someone with a bipolar disorder.
You know,
and I hate to say it,
but you have to be selfish when you're picking a mate and it says that something
you want to fucking deal with except something you feel you're capable of
dealing with.
This is the shit you have to ask yourself when you sit in there alone,
you know,
eaten Doritos with one hand down the front of your fucking sweat pants.
All right,
there you go.
I think a lot of that made a little bit of sense.
God dammit.
Somebody sent me a picture the other day,
this guy at a,
a pickup truck and on the back he had all this shit.
Um,
Anti Obama,
Obama's Asa,
his name,
Obama.
And uh,
at one point he had this,
uh,
this is what fascinates me about people who are straight up Democrat or straight
up Republican.
It reminds me of people who are into like fucking organized religion,
just like the blinders that they have on this is the bumper sticker.
This guy hit had he said,
recession,
your neighbor loses his job,
depression,
you lose your job recovery.
Obama loses his job,
you know,
and it's just like,
that was fucking people.
It's like,
how do you not see that they all kind of do the same thing and they're all on
their knees blowing the same fucking,
I mean,
don't you see?
Okay,
Clinton,
Democrat,
liberal,
right?
Bleeding,
heart liberal.
What does he do?
The bleeding,
heart liberal.
He's for the fucking everyday Joe.
He's just going to give it away to the broke people.
What does he do?
He helps deregulate the banks.
All right.
George Bush comes in,
right?
He wants to help out fucking major corporations and all that type of shit.
Doesn't give them one war.
He gives him two wars
billion dollars a fucking month of whatever the hell it is going into those
fucking cunts pockets.
God,
in the combination of those two fucking moves,
that deregulation of banks trying to fight to fucking wars,
to away games.
By the way,
on the other side of the fucking planet,
bankrupts this goddamn country.
Obama comes in,
right?
Bleeding,
heart,
fucking liberal.
What the fuck does he do?
He
gets us out of Iraq and then escalates to shit in Afghanistan.
Has he taken any of these bankers to task?
They stole a trillion dollars.
They can't even say the way the fuck it is or who got it.
Is he going after those people?
Now they're not.
It's the same fucking people.
Which is why I resent people when they tell me when I vote for Ron Paul arranged
or anybody else,
you know,
light of that ilk who saying that these bankers in these corporations are
completely out of fucking control and we need to do audit the Federal Reserve or
maybe even close the,
you know,
shut the fucking thing down and they,
they're not allowed to debate and they're just considered a crazy person.
And then you go out there and you basically make a decision between the two
fucking guys that they're giving you to vote for,
that you feel like,
oh,
we made these choices.
You didn't,
you didn't.
It's all the same fucking guy.
Hi.
He didn't figure that out in 2004 when your choice was two white guys who both
went to Yale,
who were both a member of that,
that fucking group,
the,
the skulls or whatever was the same fucking guy.
And I love how these fucking Democrats somehow get,
get off a guy,
get away with being like a,
you know,
they're all like millionaires.
Like John Kerry was a fucking Goddamn millionairey rate.
Somehow he's going to be a man of the people.
I don't fucking know.
I think,
uh,
I think at a lower level I think you can actually affect change,
um,
in political office.
But I think once you go past a certain level,
I think when even when you get to like,
if you were like a senator of your state,
I don't,
I just don't feel
that,
you know,
I dunno.
I think Obama said a bunch of shit that he was going to do,
got into office,
saw how shit works.
And right now he's trying to prevent getting shot in the fucking head.
Like everybody else who gets that job and you just,
you just do what they want you to do.
That's my,
that's my fucking 2 cents.
But these fucking morons who will,
will come along and just sit there and blame the current president if there,
of course,
if they're not a member of their party,
it's just beyond me.
It's just fucking beyond me.
Like,
uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
But,
um,
uh,
but I,
like I said,
I feel like I've,
I've talked about that enough on this fucking podcast.
People are still coming at me,
not under say understanding what I'm saying about these,
these automated checkout machines at the grocery stores.
Once again,
this guy writes me like a five page fucking email talking about pulleys and
levers and inventions from back in time.
Like I'm against fucking,
uh,
um,
progress
and he's comparing all of this.
Like,
I'm sitting there going,
fuck airplanes.
We should be back riding horses.
What about all the Black Smith who got put out of business?
I'm not talking about that.
I don't want to ride a horse to a Gig in fucking Philly.
I don't want to do that.
I love airplanes.
I don't have a problem with that shit.
I'm not talking about progress.
I'm talking about something
that,
that makes me have to work for somebody for free.
That's what I'm saying.
All right.
If they came out with those automated checkout machines and it got rid of
people's fucking jobs and,
but,
but I walked up there and it was like this thing that just,
just magically could tell me what I fucking owed without me having to do the
actual fucking job that the other person was just doing.
I wouldn't have a problem with it,
but those fucking check that they're just,
all they did was turn the cash,
register around and now I have to do it and bag my own shit.
How the is that progress?
Somebody else was trying to tell me that it's all part of this movement of,
of it was really,
really a spiritual thing.
So that we'll have all these robots,
man,
and they'll be doing all these jobs and then life will just be all about,
you know,
just exploring life cause you won't have to do a fucking job.
It's just like,
it's like,
dude,
you're completely ignoring
sociopath's
all right.
Which is why like when,
when,
uh,
as much as I lean left,
I don't go all the way to the left because that's the big flaw in,
in,
in us psycho level of,
of liberal thought is you completely ignore sociopath.
If everybody was nice,
everybody,
everything would be nice.
No it wouldn't.
They'd still be Charlie Manson.
It still be those guys,
they'd still be that guy who couldn't handle,
not fucking having more than somebody else there couldn't,
did the or the person who can't feel anything unless he's fucking poke in the
eyes of a squirrel out.
So I don't know.
My,
my,
my theory has always been that fucking hasn't always been that way.
Just just through the fucked up shit that I've read.
And God knows if it's even right,
is that sociopath's basically run the fucking world.
You know,
they have the balls to just go out and take,
and they have the,
the,
I don't know if it's a chemical makeup,
psychological makeup,
whatever it is to feel absolutely no fucking guilt.
They could give a fuck about other human beings.
They could give a fuck about nature.
They could give,
they could give a fuck.
They could give a fuck.
So
Jesus Christ,
I was so,
I'm so on my God damn soapbox.
I don't even know what the fuck I was talking about.
Oh,
getting back to that shit.
So that is my,
my,
I don't have a problem with ATS.
Okay.
Htms I basically became my own fucking teller.
But here's the big difference is I then had access to my money.
24 fucking seven you gave me a little something.
I don't have a fucking problem with that,
but I walk into a grocery store and now I'm standing behind a fucking plumber
trying to scan a week's worth to God damn groceries.
It's not quicker.
It's not.
It's,
it sucks.
Fuck you.
I,
I can't stop sending me fucking emails about pulleys and levers.
Jesus fucking Christ.
The advantage of the wheel.
He's fucking 30 fucking 40 PC.
Ugh.
Kill yourselves.
All right,
my recorder cut out again.
And it wasn't a batteries this time.
The memory was full on it or if you're of the spiritual ilk,
I think it was the podcast.
God's telling me to stop being so fucking preachy.
Um,
fuck the podcast gods.
All right.
I'm not working for fucking free.
I'm not doing that.
Those goddamn automated uh,
uh,
um,
things there when you,
when you go into a parking garage,
now we've got to stand in two fucking lines.
I got to stand behind.
Somebody tried to stuff their crinkled up dollar bill in trying to pay for their
parking and then I got to dry,
you know,
then I drive down waiting to leave and they don't get to just fucking leave
cause they gotta make sure they paid it.
They all you did was create an extra line and you eliminated the fucking parking
garage guy and now I've got to sit there and wait for the person that,
oh wait a fuck did they put the ticket that said I paid twice as God damn long.
That's what I'm talking about.
Pulley and lever guy.
I'm talking about inventions that do not make my life easier.
They just make me work for fucking free.
And the time that I spend in the store is not any shorter and a lot of times
it's a little bit fucking longer.
That's what I'm talking about,
sir.
All right,
here's a reference to last week I brought up chipped beef on toast.
Somebody from the military let me know that that's actually known as shit on a
shingle.
Um,
another here's another classic white trash meal that I had.
You guys ever have chicken.
I'll king that was like sort of chipped beef on toast without the chips of beef.
Another classic white trash meal that I had most white trash meal.
What it involves is some sort of sludge put on bread because all it is it when
it's real,
it's not about nutrition.
What it's about is taking away the pain of hunger.
And I mean,
you could literally wallpaper a room using chicken,
Allah king as your wallpaper paste.
That's how disgusting that Shit was.
Um,
I don't even know what it was mixed with.
It was sort of this gray.
I'm not quite liquid,
not quite solid.
It was like a great,
and then,
uh,
I got overly thick fucking gravy.
I mean,
it's one of those,
do you remember that when you took,
uh,
not to gross people out?
Cause this is really,
you know,
getting kind of gross here when,
when you would open the can of chicken,
Alec King and you would turn it over,
it would sort of slide out.
It would just be,
and before it finally just dropped down on the play to be,
and then there was like that,
that,
that sort of transparent gelatinous shit on the bottom of it.
It was just was fucking,
that's disgusting.
Yet somehow we weren't obese.
His kids,
it's because we were outside playing.
I think they're gradually do want to go thing with that,
with those video games now will ever,
if you play soccer now,
you actually got to sit there swinging your leg around and running and stuff.
I mean,
I guess,
uh,
I guess that's a good thing.
Right?
All right,
let's plow ahead.
Bill.
Uh,
he actually,
I got a thank you letter,
which is always nice because ever since I started talking about sports,
the level of fucking anger has really been ramped up on the,
uh,
on the emails to the point that I'm taking everything in a defensive way.
Like somebody actually sent me a hilarious email and I didn't even get it.
They said,
Bill,
once you started talking,
once you started defending bill O'Reilly last week on the podcast,
I shut,
I walked away from my recorder and I'm waiting for an apology and I was so like
read like five emails in a row of getting trashed that I wrote back.
Well,
why don't you go back and listen to what I said about,
I didn't even get the fucking joke,
the obvious joke.
They got up and walked off the view.
So my apology to that person I just had written,
I'd read like fucking five in a row where I was getting trashed.
So I was kind of in that mindset.
So my fault.
Um,
look at that.
The comedian not getting a fucking joke.
All right,
plowing ahead here.
Um,
thanks.
Here's actually something from thanks.
Yo,
Bill,
what's up?
My name is,
uh,
I can't see your name.
I'm from Little Rock,
Arkansas.
I'm 23 years old.
Sort of a new listener to the podcast.
Been a longtime fan of yours.
Uh,
but just a few months ago I discovered that you have a weekly podcasts.
Um,
anyways,
it's,
uh,
it's all great,
Yada Yada.
And anyways,
let's get to the point.
I think it was,
uh,
maybe the second or third podcast of yours I had listened to and you were like
hung over I believe,
but you said something pretty goddamn outstanding,
at least to me.
At least to me.
It was Jesus Christ.
Can you guys please use capital letters and periods?
You know,
I can't read it out loud.
Um,
and he said it was great advice you gave me.
He said it was the day when you discovered what are loser really is or was the
definition of a loser.
Anyways,
he said the definition of a loser is someone who knows what they have to do,
but they always find some way to not do it.
And then he goes on to say,
man,
that shit was like so true to me because honestly,
I've been that guy for awhile.
It's weird.
Anyways,
so it was around the same time that school was about to start up for the fall
semester.
So of course it's that time of year where my family is looming over me.
Like,
what the fuck?
When are you going to,
uh,
get your life together?
Anyways,
when you said that,
I was like,
Whoa,
okay,
so fuck it.
I got up and went to the University of Arkansas,
Little Rock,
found out what I needed to get done to get my ass back in class.
To make an already,
long story short,
I went out,
got my GED,
took the Goddamn Act test.
I don't even know what that is,
but he said,
which I failed miserably apparently.
So the school told me I had to take the compass test to get in.
Took that thing,
had to go through all the turmoil of finding my six year old high school
transcript,
which had been transferred to a billion places by then.
Um,
I wanted to say fuck it so bad during all of that crap,
but I kept repeating that shit through my head of what the definition of a loser
in any ways.
I'm halfway through my first semester as a freshman at
the University of UAA l are whatever that is.
And I have,
uh,
and I got a 98% of my midterm and I can honestly say,
if it wasn't for me listening to your podcast,
I'd still be ignoring that voice in my head.
Uh,
I'm sorry.
Still ignoring voicemails from my bitch,
grandmother,
Jesus,
dude,
trying to pes pester me into going to school.
She just wants what's best for you.
Um,
so anyways,
I want to say thanks and all that type of shit and don't be scared to tour the
south.
Me and my brother,
huge fucking fans.
And,
uh,
and he's about is Hank Williams as it gets.
Well,
that's good.
Look at that.
See,
other than pissing people off,
every once in a while I helped somebody else will.
Congratulations Dude.
Stick with that ship.
Where a condom.
That's the other one.
Respect yourself.
Where a goddamn condom.
Uh,
key and keep that fuck around until you know you're with the person you want to
marry,
then Merriam and be in a financial fucking position to bring somebody else into
the goddamn world.
Have a game plan.
Are you going to marry him?
Have the condom on while you're having that conversation.
All right.
Then have a fucking kid says the guy who's never had a fucking kid.
What the fuck do I know?
All right,
let's get to some questions and,
um,
some youtube videos and then I'm done.
Here we go.
Uh,
question.
but,
but EPITDA right.
Send some money.
Morning podcast is rolling around.
I thought it'd be interesting if you rambled about this idea.
Maybe the question is more,
when do women deserve to enjoy sex?
Um,
um,
always.
Okay,
let's delve into this one.
Um,
recently it's their fucking sex life.
They can do whatever they want with it,
right?
I recently went to a mutually agreed upon dinner with a very motivated,
independent woman who expected me to pay for dinner.
What does a mutually agreed upon dinner?
Somebody had to ask somebody to dinner,
right?
I called bullshit and refused because as I told her,
I am not in the habit of paying for people's time,
especially not people I know to be manipulative and who absolutely don't have
sex before marriage.
All right,
dude,
right off the bat,
if you don't pay for people's time,
why would you go on sort of,
not a date,
but sort of a date with somebody that you know,
manipulates people and who doesn't have sex before marriage?
Uh,
is this so you could have this argument with this person?
I mean,
you sound like an intelligent guy.
You know where the fuck this is going?
Uh,
whatever.
I'll read the rest of this,
but this is one of these things he got to get out of this Rut.
This is,
there's not plenty of good women out there the same way.
There's not plenty of good men out there.
You've got to find them,
but you can't dating the same person that's going to keep reinforcing,
uh,
your thoughts or else you're going to end up like me,
which I'm not right now because I finally found someone who was awesome,
but,
uh,
you know,
half the shit that I call women on or is the shit that I see on TV and residual
baggage that I have from dating the same fucking psycho from year,
year after year.
Ah,
Jesus Christ,
I'm really on my soapbox.
I'm gonna shut the fuck up and read.
The rest is.
But more importantly I said,
what this woman failed to understand was how much she lowered herself and is
seen by saying I need a man to pay for my meals,
which is all the same time bullshit.
The whole idea of the dating dynamic is really warped.
Where do you paying for if not sex,
you're paying for,
you're paying for sex.
What if you are paying for sex?
And I think women,
the woman forfeits her rights to have fun in bed.
Oh,
I see what you're saying,
because you're really just paying for a service at that point.
And you know what you are making points because there are women who will go out
with a guy on a Friday night because they're kind of broke in there hungry.
You know,
you can't say that shit on TV because it's considered a misogynistic.
But you know,
if you're really fair about it,
women are just like guys that they get.
If you let them get away with it,
they will.
And you sound like you're smart enough so you shouldn't be in this situation.
Um,
any continues and the whole,
whoever does the accent accent,
whoever does the ax asking pays for the meal bit is really getting tired because
the fact is women are pussies and they won't ask men out.
Yeah.
And there's also the other thing that a lot of guys get a little nervous if
women are being really forward and then like Jesus Christ,
if she's fucking asking me out,
how many Cox is,
this bitch sucked.
Oh,
um,
but why are so many women in this post feminist world?
Why are so many in women in this post feminist world,
sorry guys who have equal equal earning power as men and who even have an over
advantage in the marketplace these days.
Parentheses,
if they have a pretty face,
seem to insist on demeaning themselves to you.
You got a lot of issues here,
man.
Uh,
they have an overt advantage in the market.
They're still making less,
aren't they?
At least that's what they're always fucking run in the yaps about.
If they're good looking that it,
you know,
something that is a hell of a card to play.
If you're a hot chick,
how do you not get fucking hired?
You know what I mean?
Even if you are a fucking Bimbo,
you can go,
oh my God,
I love the carpet.
Can I have some money to be here?
He swear to God,
I'm always gonna dress hot and pretend I like you.
Um,
why do women so often refuse to step up to the plate and myth that they want to
fuck and put in their equal share?
Uh,
now that they have equal rights,
maybe there would be more satisfied couples in the world if women would learn to
do this.
Uh,
dude,
you sound like me like 10 years ago,
it sure seems to me that women are getting away with murder these days.
They cling to old school.
The ideas about paying for them to live while making a better living than the
guy they're leeching off of and expected to be pleasured wildly in bed.
How does that add up?
You can see it in newer porn now.
Wow,
dude,
you really,
you're really connected some fucking dots here that,
where do you see this in porn?
He said more and more time is being spent actually pleasuring the woman,
Eh,
Jesus really?
And all those fucking boot cocky facial
today.
I really,
out of all the examples you're going to say that,
that women are getting pleasured more in porn.
Uh,
if they are,
it's probably about fucking time.
You know,
how are they getting pleasured more?
They're,
they're not getting fucking bent over on a subway platform and getting Bang Gang
Bang.
My fucking 12 guys.
It's just one homeless dude doing it.
You know,
come on dude.
Porn porn is horrific.
You know,
occasionally,
where do women when in porn,
I think those,
those,
uh,
those strip ones where they just do the strip tease,
that one,
I think they win because there's no guy in it.
They just sort of turn the camera on this sort of in control of the whole thing.
Yet you also got to ask yourself,
why are they doing that?
What the fuck happened to them as a kid that,
uh,
you know,
eventually made them think that this is the way to make a living in the world.
You know,
like that,
like this is going to lead to happiness.
Like you can actually do this film yourself and actually go out and find a
decent husband or a person to,
to fucking settle down with some day.
Like they're going to be able to look past the fact that you were finger blast
and yourself on the Goddamn Internet.
That really sort of limits the amount of guys that you,
I don't know.
I really come from the school that most of those people were fucking abused as
kids.
I really do.
It doesn't stop me from watching it.
Um,
so anyways,
this is what I would say to you.
I know you're probably fucking mad at me because you wanted me to fucking vent
your frustrations,
but uh,
I'm trying to help you out here,
dude.
Why would you,
there's no fucking,
you know,
something that Goddamn Jersey shore,
right?
The fucking,
the Nice Guy,
Vinny.
Oh,
that dude.
Right,
right.
So like a more on here.
He went out and uh,
he met some girl down there and the whole time I guess she was,
she's been playing the guy like she was supposed to meet him at eight calls up
at eight 15.
She says she's just getting ready.
And then when he's,
when he's out to dinner with her,
she said something to the effect of like,
so will you get an upset waiting for me?
Did you think I wasn't going to show up?
And it's like right there,
right there,
right there.
You check please.
It's over.
You just fucking walk away.
Why would you wait?
You like people who manipulate our,
our are honestly some of the biggest pieces of shit on the fucking planet.
There's no way you want to hit your wagon to that.
Even for one fucking night and all it's gonna do
a male or females.
It's just going to make you hate the opposite sex more.
You're,
you're dating costs.
You're going on a date with [inaudible],
male or female.
You did this,
this,
why would you,
if you don't want to pay for somebody else's time,
all right.
That's because your time is valuable.
Why would you waste your time going out on a date with someone that you knew was
manipulative or word?
I can't say manipulative.
Manipulative,
manipulative.
That kind of sound right?
That's like learning a new drum.
Ruderman right.
You know,
just go full speed.
You've got to go right.
Left,
right,
right.
Left,
right,
left,
right.
Fuck right.
Left.
Right,
right.
Left,
right,
left,
left us.
Only makes sense.
The drummers.
Um,
so that,
that's my advice dude,
because I could really just sit here and do what the 9 million fucking rant on
women,
or I could actually maybe try to fucking help you avoid some of the pitfalls
that I,
that I went through.
There's no fucking reason.
The second male or female,
the second you figure out that you're with someone who's a cunt or you get that
feeling that the person I'm with is a cont.
Uh,
pay attention to that feeling.
All right.
When someone shows you who they are,
believe them go to a bed and if they're a client,
walk away.
All right,
real quick,
because this podcast is really long.
Uh,
I only have one youtube video of the week,
but this is almost like youtube video,
the weeks slash daily show moment of Zen.
Um,
go to the,
uh,
mm podcast.com and check this video out.
It says,
uh,
this is actually,
I found it on break.com and it's called a chick makes same dumb face in every
pick.
It's Kinda going back to that duck face.
It's,
it's actually,
it starts off funny.
Then it starts to get boring because it's so long and then it,
it becomes like,
I dunno,
it's like astounding.
The amount of pictures that this woman took with the exact same stupid fucking
look on her face.
All right.
Underrated.
Overrated for this week and then I'm out now.
Overrated.
Long a love for your fellow man.
I'm tired of being made to feel guilty because I don't care about people whose
lives are not any part of mine mostly because no one does.
No.
See because no one does and you're a hypocrite if you say you do.
We aren't designed to care about everyone.
If we,
if we were than we would have survived.
If you think about it,
I don't know what that means.
Resources or,
oh,
he's explaining it.
Resources are limited.
There's no shame in self interest.
Take care of your own.
It's a noble and honest outlook.
All right.
Underrated contests where you win something that isn't actually a prize.
I opened my flavored water and it said I want something.
I entered the code on the site to see what I won and hear what it is.
And I quote by one and I'm not gonna say the name of the water because they
pissed me off by one of these fucking waters and get one free.
Is that a prize?
No,
I think that's a fucking coupon.
You're 100% right.
CanNot agree with you more sir.
Or ma'am,
whoever wrote this,
um,
overrated Cialis disclaimer on the commercial.
Do not drink alcohol in excess with Cialis.
The fact that they said it means someone out there needs both boner pills and
excessive amounts of alcohol in order to manifest the ability,
ability to fuck whoever they're with.
Might be time to try a paper bag maybe.
Um,
all right.
Underrated to blade razors.
Surf.
I already mentioned this on the podcast,
so God bless you for backing me up.
Is it so hard to perfect the design of a shaving razor?
Is it every year they come up with a new design and how shocking they added
another blade.
Stop this bullshit marketing nonsense.
I hope no one falls for this shit to blades is all you need to.
Blades was the greatest one ever.
One digged up.
Your phase two was the greatest,
and ever since they're three or more,
you can't get those whiskers under your fucking nose.
It's a pain in the goddamn ass and it's not any closer.
I don't give a shit how many blades they have.
You know,
it's really like an unfair fight.
Like how many guys do you have to have holding the fucking whiskers arms behind
his back and you come up and fucking start working him over.
Two blades is enough.
One holds the whisker,
the other guy takes out his fucking knees.
All right.
Overrated.
Twitter.
A number of people are apparently disappointed to find out that celebrities have
normal lives in that they waste time and talk about stupid shit like everyone
else.
They must have thought they were riding around on the back of a Griffin hurling
lightning with a magic hammer all day,
underrated sleep,
sex.
This is where this person becomes creepy.
And obviously I feel this as a dude at this point.
Uh,
this is the ultimate passive aggressive move to when you can't get any.
Just wait until they're falling asleep.
Not only will they not stop you,
but they will,
but they tend to be much less critical of your performance.
Remember earlier when I was talking about sociopath running the fucking world,
this guy said overrated.
Um,
love for your fellow man or whatever the fuck the initial one was
me.
Where the hell is it?
Over?
Yeah.
Love for your fellow man.
And now he's talking about how sleep sex,
which really seems like a form of rape,
sort of rape life,
sort of a light,
uh,
sexual assault.
Okay.
That,
that one's just creepy sir.
And uh,
and with that,
I think I'm done reading underrated,
overrated at this point.
I don't want to see what the next two one go the next to next to ones go the
next to go out.
Who gives a fuck?
Anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
God bless all of you.
Please come down.
I'm doing a benefit in Saint Louis.
Support the cause.
I have all the information up on my website and uh,
if not,
if you just want to see me,
uh,
cause that show,
I think I'm just doing 15,
20 minutes.
But if you want to see the full on me,
come to the Saint Louis funny bone this Saturday night,
which is Saturday,
October 30th,
the night before Halloween.
Ah,
come on down.
I'm doing two shows at the funny bone.
Seven 30 and 10 o'clock.
I've got my brand new hour of material.
I'll have my brand new DVD.
I'll have a brand new fucking shirt on.
Everything's going to be brand new.
Come on down.
All right,
that's it.
God bless all of you.
Have a great [inaudible].
[inaudible]
in your case,
shoot me
his dad.
I don't take it down.
She's in Latin.
You can shoot me.
She Cs and you dare to try.
I sit him not,
don't shoot your little woman.
My daughter's best shot gun.
It just won't fly.